Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Wusstest du schon, wo es Internet gibt, gibt es Ruhm und Träume.
Ja vor allem Träume wahrscheinlich dann, ne?
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 474 vom, was haben wir denn heute, 2.
November 2023 und uns gibt's jetzt seit zwölf Jahren.
Stimmt, letztes Wochenende.
Ja, hab ich wieder mit so einem KI erzeugten Bild gefeiert. Auf Mastodon.
Ja, das hab ich sogar gesehen.
Wie man das so macht heutzutage.
Und ja, mehr gibt's dazu eigentlich auch nichts zu sagen.
Habe ich retweetet auf Mastodon.
Brav, brav, brav, brav.
Retootet oder wie heißt das denn? Da muss man ja aufpassen.
Ich bin dafür, dass man das Retweet nennt. Weißt du warum?
Ja ich nenn's auch so.
Weil dieses ganze wir müssen das anders nennen als Twitter Ding ist ja jetzt eigentlich durch.
Also kann man das jetzt so ein bisschen wie mit Tempotaschentuch und so weiter handhaben.
Hätte man auch vorher schon machen können.
Hätte man, hat man wahrscheinlich auch schon. Ich kann auch auf Bing googlen.
Klar kannst du auf Bing googeln und das ist auch völlig in Ordnung wenn du das machst.
Ja man kann aber nicht auf Google bingen. Also es ist schon relativ klar was
gemeint ist und wenn man jetzt retweetet, es gibt so viele gute Retweet Witze auch.
Ja das ist, man muss ja auch nicht alles, also diese, also Mastodon,
in allen Ehren, aber mit dieser ganzen Benennung haben die einfach kein glückliches Händchen.
Du nennst das Ding Mastodon und dann muss man da tooten und dann retooten und
dann tröten und dann darfst du nicht Twitter sagen, dann musst du Birdside sagen, das ist...
Tut ist doch im amerikanischen Sprachgebrauch auch die Bezeichnung für einen kleinen Pforz.
Das kann gut sein.
Ja. Würde mich nicht wundern. Hast du das schon repforzt?
Ja, wenigstens haben sie nix mit Fist gemacht oder so.
Lassen wir das, vertiefen wir das nicht. Ich wollte dir ein Gedicht vorlesen,
um mal herauszufinden, was denn?
Achso, ich wollte mich noch fragen, wann die Auflösung kommt,
warum es Ruhm und Träume beim Internet gibt, aber das ist wahrscheinlich jetzt die Auflösung, ne?
Quasi, ja, genau.
Ja, will ich hören.
Also, es fängt so an. Mit Loyalität und Hingabe wachen wir Tag und Nacht über
unser Gebiet, um unserer Mission zu dienen, während die Sonne im Osten aufgeht.
Jeden Tag schaffend mit Innovation und seine Helligkeit umarmend wie ein Strahl der Integrität,
der dein Herz bewegt, vereinen wir die Kraft aller Lebewesen,
leisten einen Beitrag zum globalen Dorf, um es in seiner schönsten Form zu entwickeln.
Das ist die erste Strophe? Und dann geht's weiter. Eine Internetmacht.
Wo es Internet gibt, gibt es Ruhm und Träume. Eine Internetmacht.
Vom fernen Kosmos bis zu den Häusern, die wir vermissen.
Und jetzt muss ich dich fragen, ob du schon irgendeine Ahnung hast,
wovon ich hier rede, weil alles andere würde es jetzt schon ein bisschen aufdecken.
Von uns. Wahrscheinlich ein Gedicht über uns.
Also es handelt von Ruhm und Internet, also dachte ich mal direkt Tim und Linus.
Ja also das ist jetzt von mir so ein bisschen hilfsübersetzt,
aus dem englischen, was wiederum aus einer anderen Sprache übersetzt wurde,
damit man es auf englisch zur Erkenntnis nehmen kann.
Und der Titel der da kolportiert wird ist The Mind and Spirit of Cyberspace
Security. Der Geist und die Seele der Cyberspace Sicherheit.
Ja, das singe ich morgens immer auf dem Weg zur Arbeit.
Wirklich? Ja, ja klar. So ungefähr hier so irgendwie so.
Also, um es aufzuklären, das hier ist sozusagen die Haushymne der chinesischen
Cyber Security Agentur.
Der Chinesischen? Aha. Ja.
Es geht nämlich weiter mit eine Internetmacht. Sie erzählt der Welt,
dass der chinesische Traum China aufrichtet.
Eine Internetmacht. Jeder einzelne repräsentiert die ganze Nation.
Du kannst dir vorstellen, da gibt's ein passendes Video, das werden wir ja am
Ende auch nochmal akustisch einblenden.
Da stehen sie dann in so einem großen Chor und singen von der großen Kraft und
Freude, die ganze Cybersecurity Tätigkeit macht in diesem Universum,
so wie alle Flüsse treu nach dem Meer suchen.
So tragen sie Chinas große Kultur und messen Chinas Größe und so weiter.
Also es ist vollkommen überdreht und manchmal weiß ich echt nicht,
was ich von den Chinesen so halten soll, um ehrlich zu sein.
Aber man muss ihnen ja lassen, fett auftragen.
Können sie wirklich richtig gut.
Also die machen echt immer gleich so eine ganz dicke Nummer.
Das ist aber doch bei jeder Hymne so.
Ja aber nicht nur bei Hymnen. Also generell machen sie alles immer so unglaublich
groß und pompös und tralala und hauen alles raus und ich meine so Olympia,
du erinnerst dich, solche Events.
Erinner ich mich nicht.
Man kann ja alles scheiße finden was sie machen, aber man muss ihnen zumindest
zugestehen, fett kriegen sie irgendwie gut hin.
Ich erinnere mich noch an diese Olympiade, nicht dass ich mich besonders dafür
interessieren würde, ich hab's aber trotzdem mitverfolgt.
Dann haben sie ja erstmal krasse Stadien gebaut und dann allein schon diese
Eröffnungsfeier, die sie da abgezogen haben, das war so over the top,
das war von allem einfach viel zu viel, aber halt irgendwie auch krass.
Also das ist einfach, jetzt guckst du dir das an und denkst ja nur so,
ihr habt sie doch nicht alle.
Aber nein sie müssen Chinas Größe ins Universum raus demonstrieren.
Und unter anderem, ich frage mich, ob die bei der NSA auch so einen Song haben.
Was hat denn, Private Manning hat doch irgendwie auf die CD was drauf geschrieben.
Ich glaube da stand drauf Britney Spears oder sowas. Der Rohling quasi,
um die Daten aus diesem Geheimraum zu exfiltrieren, da stand Britney Spears drauf oder sowas.
Achso, Oops I did it again oder was?
Ich weiß es nicht. Gerade im militärischen Bereich musst du dir doch jetzt wirklich
bei den Amerikanern keine Sorgen machen,
dass die es versäumen dick aufzutragen oder theatralisch von Heldentaten zu singen.
Also ich weiß, ich habe ja mit einer,
ich habe ja in den USA gelebt und ich habe da mit Familien gelebt,
die auch Leute zum Militärentsand hatten, ja also und dadurch habe ich auch
irgendwie so Airbases und so irgendwelche Bootcamp Abschlusszelebrationen und so.
Jedes fucking Basketball Team einer Highschool wird einmarschiert mit ner Marching Band.
Also, ähm, bzw.
Basketball begleitet die Band beim Football, marschiert sie dann auf,
also marschiert wir traditionell auf Fußballfeldern, also ein pisseliges Highschool
Football Match wird da zelebriert.
Da kommt dann irgendwie die schönste Schülerin der Woche und muss die Hymne singen.
Ja, also da kannst du jetzt nicht die Amerikaner nicht auch würdigen in ihrem Dickauftrag.
Ne, also definitiv sind sie auch im Club der Dickauftragenden,
da sind sie ganz gut, aber da steht ihnen halt China auch in nichts nach und
ich würde halt sagen, man erinnert sich an diese Drohnenmalerei im Himmel,
das haben die Chinesen zuerst gemacht.
Feuerwerk auch.
Ja, genau. Feuerwerk auch. Siehst du mal. Guter Punkt. Das meine ich.
Nur die haben sich dann irgendwann mal weiterentwickelt.
Wer jetzt? Die Amerikaner?
Nee, die Chinesen haben sich weiterentwickelt. Die Amerikaner?
Immer weiter bumm bumm bumm.
Und Deutsche auch. Knall, knall, toll. Hier Finger ab und weiter.
Nee die Schleser haben irgendwann gedacht, nee machen wir besser.
Okay, aber also dürfen wir das auch singen oder wie bist du jetzt da drauf gekommen?
Mir ist es so über den Weg gelaufen und ich dachte mir das könnte man ja mal
gewinnbringend machen.
Aber bevor ich jetzt, ich hatte schon vor diesen kurzen Clip anstatt des Intros
zu spielen, aber da ja alles so verstört war.
Was ich ja irgendwie auch ganz charmant finde, dass ich mir so… Nein,
hab ich ja auch nicht gemacht, ich hab's so gemacht.
Man kann sich auch mal entschuldigen, wenn man zu weit gegangen ist.
Komm.
Ihr könnt das schon ver...
Vincenz, bezüglich des anderen Intro-Sounds, ich dachte kurz mir ist der Bordcomputer
vom Auto abgeschmiert oder mein Telefon explodiert gleich,
alles während ich mich in einer Autobahn-Kreuzung orientieren muss,
wenn schon Linus geprankt werden muss, fände ich es gut als Hörer vorgewarnt zu werden.
So, das ist einfach die strengste Zurechtweisung, die hier mit absoluter rechtlicher
Grundlage vorgetragen werden.
Autobahnkreuzung ist übrigens auch saugefährlich.
Oh man.
Also Autobahnkreuzung, hoffentlich wenn dann wenigstens mit Ampeln.
Aber so eine Autobahnkreuzung klingt auf jeden Fall gefährlich.
Autobahnkreuzung mit Ampeln, das ist ein Widerspruch in sich. ich
glaube die heißen autobahnkreuz oder genau aber
eine autobahnkreuzung ist nicht vorfahrt von
rechts also die definition von
autobahn ist dass es sich dabei um eine kreuzungsfreie fahrbahn handelt also
nicht dass man die cdu also man könnte natürlich mal langsamer anfangen die
autobahn zu kreuzigen also eine Autobahnkreuzigung wiederum, da wäre ich dann dabei.
Naja, okay, also ich hab ja mit Leid ein bisschen, ne, ihr kleinen Schlüflocken,
aber naja, ihr wollt es halt immer gleich haben, wie schön.
Dann haben wir ja relativ viel über Machine Learning und Deep Learning in der
letzten Sendung gesprochen.
Und da wurden natürlich allerlei Feinheiten sofort bemerkt,
zum Beispiel, dass ich die ganze Zeit Machine Learning gesagt habe,
aber Deep Learning beschrieben habe, was in meinen Augen eigentlich eine,
also diese Aufteilung kann man natürlich machen,
unter Machine Learning fällt im weitesten Sinne noch,
Also Regressionsanalyse könntest du Machine Learning nennen oder einfache lineare
Modelle und Deep Learning ist halt das verschalten mehrerer,
das was ich beschrieben habe, das verschalten mehrerer Layer.
Das ist halt sozusagen die Version 2.0 davon, Machine Learning gab es auch schon
vorher über Jahrzehnte und dann kam irgendwann der Knaller Deep Learning.
Genau, auch das gab es schon vorher, aber wie dem auch sei, aber auf jeden Fall finde ich ganz schön,
wie sich in der Diskussion das widerspiegelt, der schreibt MG Berberich,
Machine Learning wendet man dann an, wenn man das Problem, das man lösen möchte,
nicht verstanden hat oder nicht verstehen will.
Denn wenn man das Problem verstanden hätte, könnte man es modellieren und viel
effizienter und zuverlässiger konventionell lösen.
Ein Großteil der KI-Aktivitäten, Forschung will ich das nicht nennen,
besteht einfach darin, völlig hirnlos die Netze immer größer zu machen und über
mehr Daten optimieren zu lassen, bis es irgendwann halbwegs funktioniert.
Auch der Begriff lernen ist bei diesen Systemen unangebracht.
Das, was die machen, hat mit Lernen, wie wir es von Menschen oder Tieren kennen, nichts zu tun.
Das sieht man schon daran, dass einem Kleinkind ein paar Bilder einer Giraffe
ausreichen, um Giraffen zu erkennen.
Während Machine-Learning-Systeme unendlich viele gelabelte Bilder brauchen.
Und danach kann das Kind erklären, woran es eine Giraffe erkennt.
Während beim ML-System niemand weiß, was die eigentlich machen.
Das ist ein ziemlich ineffizienter, nicht-linearer Optimierungsprozess auf einem
typischerweise völlig überdimensionierten System.
Und den Kommentar finde ich sehr gut, weil er ein paar Sachen sehr,
sehr, sehr klar herausstellt, ein paar Sachen aber, naja, nicht so wirklich erklären kann, ne.
Ich glaube, deswegen habe ich noch ein paar andere Kommentare reingenommen.
Der Vergleich mit dem, mit dem Kleinkind, dem man ein paar Bilder einer Giraffe
zeigt und das kann dann erkennen, kann die dann erkennen, ja.
Der ignoriert, dass das Kind zu dem Zeitpunkt schon drei Jahre Gehirnentwicklung hinter sich hat.
Also auf dem Weg hat es schon sprechen gelernt, auf dem Weg hat es gelernt,
was ein Tier ist, was eine Pflanze ist und so weiter.
Und auf der Basis zeigst du dem Kind dann irgendwann drei Giraffen und das Kind
sagt, es ist eine Giraffe.
Also der Vergleich hinkt so ein bisschen,
weil wenn wir auf eine spezifische Tätigkeit gucken,
also Go spielen oder so, dann kann man sagen, wie oft hast du das jetzt gelernt,
aber wenn du diese generalisierende Intelligenz eines Kindes nimmst,
dann musst du dem Kind eben auch sagen, ja gut, der hat drei Jahre gebraucht
und die ersten paar Jahre oder die ersten paar Monate hättest du bei jedem Computerexperiment
nicht weitergemacht, weil das einfach überhaupt nichts gelernt hat oder scheinbar
überhaupt nichts gelernt hat bzw.
Die ganze Zeit nur gelernt hat und währenddessen gefüttert werden musste oder so.
Nicht nur das, also es kommen ja auch noch ein paar Millionen Jahre Evolution
des Gehirns dazu, also es ist ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass wir komplett bei
null starten würden, sondern da ist ja auch schon das eine oder andere abgelegt in unserer DNA.
Da sind sensible Sensibilitäten und so. Aber genau, der Vergleich ist natürlich
trotzdem ganz gut. Und vor allem, was er sagt, ist ja richtig.
Ein Großteil der KI-Aktivitäten besteht darin, einfach völlig hirnlos Netze
immer größer zu machen und immer mehr Daten reinzuwerfen.
Stimmt, auch das ist einfach mal wahr. Aber offenbar gibt es ein paar Leute, die es geschafft haben.
Mit dieser Technologie gezielt umzugehen und faszinierende Ergebnisse zu schaffen.
Also ich glaube, das verblasst jetzt,
also das ist eine sehr gute Einschätzung der Machine-Learning-Aktivitäten generell,
aber verblasst ein bisschen vor dem, was jetzt eben innerhalb des letzten Jahres
einige damit geschafft haben.
Mit sehr viel Geld, mit sehr viel Ineffizienz, alles richtig.
Aber gerade wenn man sich so diese Bildgenerierungsdinger anschaut,
ja, dann realisieren die dann doch schon eine ganze Menge Dinge,
die auch ein Kind nicht in drei oder zehn Jahren so schnell hinkriegt.
Ja vor allem, das ist ganz lustig, die ganze Diskussion macht sich oft an diesen Bildern fest.
Und dann haben wir über so Sachen wie Ton modifizieren und Stimmen nachspüren noch gar nicht geredet,
aber wovon überhaupt keiner redet, was man so ein bisschen mal so nebenbei zur Kenntnis nimmt,
ist, dass diese Systeme nahezu in jeder Sprache sprechen können und verstehen
können und irgendwie flüssig von einem Dialogteil zum nächsten,
von der einen auf die andere Sprache sprechen.
Also ML Deep Learning hat es mal eben geschafft in den letzten Jahren dieses
generelle Bubblefish Problem zu lösen.
Das ist vielleicht jetzt noch ein Hauch ganz kurz zu früh, aber wir sind da
sehr sehr weit gekommen auf einmal.
Es gab da einen riesen Schub, das war bis vor kurzem noch ein echtes Problem
und für Übersetzer gab es ein paar spezifische Programme hier und da.
Und dann kam als erstes DeepL und jetzt mittlerweile nahezu alle Large Language
Models hinterher, die das einfach hervorragend hinbekommen.
Und genau das meint nämlich Marc, wenn ich den Kommentar ganz kurz einstreue,
halte deinen Gedanken, sonst nimmst du den Kommentar weg.
Er antwortet nämlich auf den M. G.
Berberich, denn wenn man das Problem verstanden hätte, könnte man es modellieren
und viel effizienter und zuverlässiger konventionell lösen. Darauf antwortet er.
Nur, dass dieser Ansatz in den letzten Jahrzehnten zuverlässig in eine Sackgasse
geführt hat. Nimm das Beispiel Sprachverarbeitung.
Hier sind Erkennungsraten möglich geworden, von denen regelbasierte Ansätze nur träumen konnten.
Und diese Modelle arbeiten nicht im Labor, sondern in hochskalierten,
antwortzeitsensiblen Callcenter-Geschäften.
Also genau das, was du sagtest, dass es nämlich irre Ergebnisse schafft und,
Jetzt darfst du weitersprechen, weil ich nicht mehr weiß, was ich sage.
Ja gut, also guter Hinweis und er geht ja sogar noch einen Schritt weiter mit seinem Beispiel,
dass wir also sozusagen auch schon nicht nur so ein langsam vor sich hin tippenden
Chatbot haben, sodass man noch schön mitlesen kann, was mich ja persönlich an
dieser ganzen Geschichte am meisten freut.
Das ist ja wieder so wie früher am Akustik-Koppler, also wo man noch die Zeichen
lesen konnte, während sie übertragen wurden. Das hat schon was.
Aber davon abgesehen sind wir jetzt eben schon im Realtime-Geschäft,
deswegen ist vielleicht auch der Vergleich mit dem Babelfisch,
also wer das nicht kennt,
aus dem Buch Per Anatole durch die Galaxis, dieser kleine Fisch,
den man sich ins Ohr steckt und der sich von, wie war das du gesagt,
von Gehirnwellen ernährt und dabei sozusagen Sprache automatisch,
so als Abfallprodukt übersetzt.
Und ja, das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich auch so kommen.
Also diese Airpods sind schon sehr nah dran, jetzt musst du das nur noch mit
einer Software koppeln, die halt in Echtzeit übersetzt.
Die gibt es im Prinzip auch schon. Also es gibt so Apps, Google Translate,
pipapo, verschiedene Systeme.
Ich hab mich jetzt mit dem Bereich nicht so spezifisch beschäftigt in letzter Zeit,
aber das ist jetzt eigentlich nur noch eine Frage der Zeit, Ich fahre jetzt
in den nächsten Tagen nach Italien,
mir wurde gesagt da wo ich hinfahre da spricht keiner Englisch,
ich spreche kein Englisch,
es gibt auch Spanien da sprechen die mittlerweile auch Englisch aber ich fahre
ja nach Neapel und mir wurde von jemandem der gerade in Neapel ist gesagt,
Muss ja echt schon mit Italienisch oder Händen und Füßen sowas.
Anderes gibts hier nicht.
Und jetzt gehst du mit deinen Airpods und deinem Google Translator hin.
Ja genau. Und sage ich möchte diese Schallplatte nicht kaufen, sie ist zerkratzt.
Ich habe gar kein Auto, musst du den sagen.
Ich möchte noch ganz kurz diesen Gedanken ein bisschen weiterführen mit dieser Sparverarbeitung,
weil da kommentiert Luki Puki, Ähm, sagt also AlphaGo,
AlphaGo Zero, bei der ersten gab es Trainingsdaten von menschlichen Spielen,
ja, und ähm, die hat quasi schon mal als Intuition überhaupt mit menschlichem Handeln angefangen,
ja, und dann haben sie eine nächste gemacht, die hieß irgendwie AlphaZero,
der haben sie nur die Regeln gegeben und von Anfang an sie gegen sich selber spielen lassen.
Und diese neuere Variante AlphaZero war anschließend besser als AlphaGo und
war schneller dort angelangt.
Und jetzt kommt der entscheidende Satz. Es geht sozusagen um die traurige Erkenntnis,
dass unser menschliches Wissen und wie wir Dinge verstehen eigentlich kontraproduktiv ist.
Wenn wir also menschliches Wissen in solche Systeme reinprogrammieren,
behindern wir die beim Finden von optimalen Lösungen.
Ja, das ist wieder so eine menschliche kränkung von der
oben geschrieben wurde nicht nur sind wir nicht die mitte
des universums unser verständnis vom Universum ist
eigentlich kontraproduktiv wenn man wirklich das universum verstehen
will Hoffentlich denken die maschinen nicht hey wir sind eigentlich besser dran
wenn wir die menschen erst mal platt machen und bei null anfangen Und dann hat
er noch das bin ich gerade übergangen ein cv von dir referenziert zu neuronalen
netzen Acht Jahre oder so alt, ja.
Ich zitiere mal, wie er die Situation erzählt, von irgendeiner Nationalbibliothek
oder sowas, wo jahrelang schlaue Linguistinnen daran gearbeitet haben,
dieses Wissen durch Computer zu verstehen, also die Sprache zu analysieren.
Am Ende kamen AI-Leute mit Word2Vec, was einfach alle Daten einliest,
ohne sich um die linguistischen Kategorien zu kümmern. Was ist ein Verb,
was ist ein Satz, was ist ein Substantiv?
Alle diese Modelle, die Menschen sich für das Verstehen von Sprache ausgedacht
hatten, ignoriert das einfach. Und das Ergebnis war viel besser als alles,
was die schlauesten Linguisten in Jahrzehnten geschafft haben.
Und es war extrem simpel.
Liest also irgendwie nur ein kleines Fenster von aufeinander folgenden Worten
ein und ist völlig egal ob das jetzt Sätze sind oder nicht.
Genau, also ein schönes Beispiel, also dieses Word2Vec hat einfach den Text
einfach genommen und hat sozusagen die Struktur selber entdeckt.
Vielleicht erinnert ihr euch auch noch an diese, es kommt auch aus der Zeit
2013, 14, 15, da ging das mit diesen Deep Dreams los.
Also es waren sozusagen diese ersten Deep Learning Algorithmen von Google,
die dann mal visualisiert wurden, also wo man quasi dieses,
wie soll man das beschreiben, also dieses Deep Learning, du hast das ja letztes
Mal schon so schön erläutert,
ist dieses mehrstufige, immer tiefergehende und man muss sich das sozusagen
so vorstellen, dass man eben den Daten immer mehr Abstraktion hinzufügt,
so würde ich es mal sagen.
Und das wurde dann in diesen Deep-Dream-Videos visualisiert,
wo man erstmal durch so eine rauschende Pixelwolke durchgeht und dann auf der
Suche nach Hunden und Katzen irgendwie auf einmal so ein permanenter Schwall
von Augen und anderen Körper identifizierenden Objekten auf einen zuströmen.
Und das heißt dieses ganze wo ist irgendetwas, das können diese Machine Learning,
Deep Learning Algorithmen mehr oder weniger von alleine herausfinden.
Und das ist halt eigentlich das besondere daran, dass wir jetzt eine Software
Technik haben, die in der Lage ist selber diese Strukturen zu sich zu erarbeiten.
Und deswegen wirkt das eben auch so intelligent, weil.
Man kann halt, wenn man so mit Chachipiti arbeitet, da kann man halt,
einfach was weiß ich, Also das war wirklich so die Erkenntnis in dem Moment.
Und da hat er finde ich auch sehr schön herausgearbeitet, dass da im Prinzip alles angefangen hat.
Die Technik ist jetzt also ungefähr ein Jahrzehnt alt.
Und dann hat natürlich, wie sollte es anders sein, der kluge Hans kommentiert.
– Der weiß immer Bescheid, der kluge Hans.
– Ich bin etwas überrascht, wie oberflächlich ihr auf den Wunsch nach KI-Regulierung eingeht.
Aktuell ist die Situation so, dass jemand nachts eine Kiste Zauberstäbe auf
den Dorfplatz gestellt hat.
Nebst Schild viel Spaß.
Sodass alle von der verantwortungsbewussten, akademisch gebildeten,
queerfreundlichen Integrationsbeauftragten bis hin zum 15-jährigen,
testosterongesteuerten Pickelpöbler mit Alkoholproblemen und Rechtsdreieck zugreifen
dürfen, egal ob sie damit bunte Blumen im Vorgarten sprießen lassen oder den
Dachstuhl des Nachbarn abfackeln.
Ist es zu viel verlangt, dass man, bevor man eine potenziell so grundlegend
verändernde Erneuerung auf die Allgemeinheit loslässt, sich Gedanken darüber
macht, ob es irgendeine Art der Qualifikation seitens der Nutzer geben sollte.
Das geht natürlich über eine rein juristische Definition hinaus in eine gesellschaftliche Betrachtung.
Die Aussage Tims, dass eine Regulierung nicht die Ursache löse,
greift doch viel zu kurz.
Wir haben doch auch ein Strafgesetzbuch, in dem nur die Konsequenzen von Delikten
betrachtet werden und dann zusätzliche Mechanismen,
um zum Beispiel Kriminalität aus einer persönlichen Notsituation zu minimieren.
Richtig. Überwachungstechnik wie Kameras sind immer kleiner und billiger geworden
und deswegen war die Konsequenz daraus nicht, alle Kameras zu verbieten.
Aber trotzdem muss doch von Seiten des Gesetzgebers auf diese sich verändernde Situation.
Beispiel Upskirting musste 1910 nicht reguliert werden, da der Fotograf es nur
schwer geschafft hätte, sein Stativ und die Schuhkarton-große Plattenkamera
unter dem Reifrock einer Dame zu positionieren, ohne dass die das gemerkt hätte.
KI ist ein mächtiger Hebel, der alle Möglichkeiten positiv wie negativ verstärken kann.
Da fände ich es doch sinnvoll zu diskutieren, ob man dafür eine gewisse Befähigung
erlernen sollte oder ob die Nutzung auf bestimmte dafür ausgebildete und dafür
auch verantwortlich machbare Kreise oder auch Bereiche begrenzt bleiben sollte.
Zu guter Letzt sollte man nicht vergessen, dass die Bereitstellung dieser KI-Dienste
nicht aus reiner Menschenfreude stattfindet, sondern dass alle daran beteiligten
Firmen in erster Linie ein Geschäft darin sehen.
Ein Geschäft, das nicht aus einer reinen Dienstleistung besteht,
sondern parallel auch im Erfassen persönlicher Daten und Nutzungsverhaltens.
Wenn ich höre, dass inzwischen daran geforscht wird, beim Digitalkonsum direkt
auf das Gehirn zuzugreifen, natürlich nur, um den Service zu verbessern,
indem man den Middleman, also das Eingabegerät, eliminiert.
Heißt das also, indem man versucht, das Nutzerverhalten auch physiologisch festzuhalten,
wie zum Beispiel früher bei Eye-Tracking, und damit für mich keine Möglichkeit mehr besteht,
dem Computer meine Absichten oder Emotionen vorzuenthalten, wird doch klar,
dass jede derart umwälzende technische Neuerung das Potenzial hat,
das Leben nicht nur zu verbessern, verbessern, sondern auch zur dystopischen
Hölle werden zu lassen und es in entscheidendem Ausmaß davon abhängt, wer sie wie benutzt.
Also stimmt, ich finde einen Aspekt ein bisschen gefährlich und das ist der,
ich wiederhole das nochmal, KI ist ein mächtiger Hebel, der alle Möglichkeiten
positiv wie negativ verstärken kann.
Da sollte man doch diskutieren, ob die Nutzung auf bestimmte,
dafür ausgebildete und auch verantwortlich machbare Kreise oder auch Bereiche
begrenzt bleiben sollte.
Kreise, würde ich jetzt dann denken, heißt dann irgendwie Menschen,
denen man dazu Zugang gibt?
Und jetzt überlege ich mal, was passiert, wenn man zu einer so mächtigen Technologie
jetzt nur wenigen Menschen Zugang gibt.
Und nicht irgendwie allen. Dann bedeutet das ja, dass diese wenigen diese Technologie
ausnutzen werden, um die anderen auf jeden Fall nicht zu bevorteiligen.
Also da bin ich mir echt nicht so sicher, ob das gut ist,
so etwas von der Allgemeinheit fernzuhalten, um dann zu argumentieren,
wenn man das von der Allgemeinheit fernhält, dann profitiert die Allgemeinheit
mehr. Da bin ich noch nicht sovon überzeugt.
Ja, ich meine jetzt sind wir im klassischen Chancen und Risiken Diskussionsbereich
und ich finde ja auch nicht, dass man das nicht diskutieren darf.
Das darf man diskutieren. Ich komme nicht unbedingt jetzt zu denselben Konsequenzen
hier. Also ich meine das ist salopp gesagt, da haben wir wieder eine schöne
deutsche Verburtsdiskussion.
Etwas kann vielleicht böse sein, deswegen muss es irgendwie begrenzt,
reguliert, im Zugriff eingeschränkt bestimmten Gruppen vorenthalten werden und
es muss eine Haftung eingeführt werden.
Das ist mir ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen zu heftig, weil das einfach mal den
Chancenteil komplett ignoriert.
Und auf den kann man ja genauso gut auch ein Anrecht haben.
Wer entscheidet denn mir diese Chance zu nehmen, hier vielleicht auch was gutes
daraus zu machen, nur weil es andere Doofe gibt.
Klar Risiko ist immer da, aber das hat man einfach mit jeder Technologie und
ich fühle mich nicht wohl dabei jetzt irgendwie diesem Machine Learning und
Deep Learning und AI oder wie man es auch immer nennen soll,
da jetzt so einen Sonderstatus zu geben, weil es,
Hatten wir ja letztes mal auch schon. Es ist halt eine Zeitenwende,
eine technologische Zeitenwende, so wie das Internet eine technologische Zeitenwende
war, so wie es das Telefon war.
Und immer wurde das Schlimmste heraufbeschworen, was theoretisch passieren kann,
was Bücher schon alles auslösen würden. Und das muss auch auf jeden Fall beschränkt
werden und so, der Name der Rose.
Also das, abgesehen davon, dass es nicht funktionieren würde,
also wie willst du den Zugriff auf die Technik verhindern?
Also das ist irgendwie Open Source, das wird überall entwickelt,
das ist jetzt einfach das Ding, das wird überall sein, das wird in jedem Betriebssystem
sein, das wird in jedem Telefon sein und das wird in jeder App drin sein.
Wird es einfach, ist es teilweise auch schon.
Das kriegst du eh nicht wieder zurückgefahren und man muss es vielleicht auch
nicht unbedingt zurückfahren.
Gibt's Bedarf für Regulierung? Vielleicht. Wissen wir schon,
was genau eigentlich jetzt reguliert werden soll? Ich habe da so meine Zweifel.
Wir haben es irgendwie derzeit noch mit einer Entscheider-Generation zu tun,
die immer noch Schwierigkeiten hat zu verstehen, was der Sinn eines allgemeinen
Glasfaserausbaus in Deutschland ist, um mal überall irgendwie gleichberechtigt
Internetzugang zu realisieren.
Da sind wir noch nicht drüber hinaus gekommen und jetzt sollen dieselben Leute
irgendwie entscheiden, wie man bei KI, die Technologie, die im Prinzip jetzt
in dieser Form, wie wir sie jetzt erleben, gerade mal seit zehn Monaten am Start
ist, wie wir da in Zukunft mit umgehen wollen.
Ich habe doch meine Zweifel, dass das überhaupt gelingen kann.
Ja und ich denke das ist genau das, was ich in der letzten Folge auch so ein bisschen sagen wollte.
Man muss das schon verstanden haben, bevor man es reguliert.
Idealerweise, wenn man jetzt sagt, man kann so ein paar Sachen machen,
wo man vielleicht sagt, wenn man das reguliert, macht man auf jeden Fall erstmal
keinen Fehler. Zum Beispiel wie, lass uns den Dingern erstmal keine Waffen geben, ja?
Das ist so, weißt du, da nimmt man eine ganze Menge Risiko weg, ja?
Ohne sich großartiger Chancen zu berauben, ja?
Zumindest in der Allgemeinheit.
Andere Dinge, wie das darf in der Medizin nicht angewendet werden oder,
ich nehme jetzt Beispiele.
Da beschneidet man sich potenziell sehr Wohlmöglichkeiten. Da kann man das noch nicht so sagen.
Nicht nur potenziell, sondern ich würde sagen, das wäre die größte Dummheit von allen.
Ich wollte ja jetzt mal ein paar Dummheiten mir eindämmen. Ich glaube nicht,
dass das irgendjemand fordert. Ganz im Gegenteil wird ja hier diese Brustgripsfruherkennung
auch immer als eines der Steckenpferde genannt.
Aber um mal Beispiele zu nennen und das darf jetzt nicht über Menschen entscheiden,
muss immer nochmal ein Mensch machen.
Da haben wir ja auch schon das letzte Mal drüber gesprochen,
dass das im Zweifelsfall aufgrund der Automatisme, mit denen Menschen sich so
einer Aufgabe dann widmen, auch keine große Sicherheit mehr bringen wird.
Also solange das nicht wirklich abschätzbar ist und vor allem solange Leute
sich jetzt alles mögliche einbilden,
was irgendwie schief gehen kann und so weiter, ist es nicht verkehrt,
vielleicht auch erstmal ein bisschen was gewähren zu lassen.
Nehmen wir uns mal ein Problem heraus, wo wir glaube ich alle relativ einig
sind, dass es eins ist oder dass es ein bereits existierendes Problem ist.
Noch schlimmer machen wird. Das mit den Fake-Bildern, dass man also jetzt hier
quasi in absehbarer Zeit alles fotorealistisch fälschen kann.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Problem.
Und jetzt kann man überlegen, wir versuchen die Nutzung dieser Technologie einzuschränken,
dann wird das dazu führen, dass nur noch Wladimir Putin, Xi Jinping und wie
heißt der durchgeknallte Nordkoreaner das haben?
Kim Jong-un.
Ich wollte ihn nur lieber durchgeknallter Nordkoreaner nennen.
Ich glaub das heißt das auch auf Nordkoreanisch.
Genau ich wollte es übersetzen.
Und da hast du dann auch nix von, weil du dann nämlich eine unmündige Gesellschaft hast.
Ich schätze, wir müssen da jetzt halt durch eine bittere Zeit mit ein paar echt unschönen Phänomenen,
damit es irgendwann alle gelernt haben, aber Medienkompetenz oder ein Mangel
an Medienkompetenz durch Vorenthaltung dieser Medien kompensieren zu wollen,
ist glaube ich auf jeden Fall keine nachhaltige Herangehensweise.
Ne ich meine wie willst du Führerscheine ausgeben, wenn die Leute überhaupt
gar keine Möglichkeit haben, überhaupt erst mal irgendwelche Erfahrungen damit
zu sammeln. Also das funktioniert nicht.
Führerscheine kann man dann machen, wenn man klare Regeln hat so und die hat
man aber auch erst im Straßenverkehr eingeführt, nachdem der Straßenverkehr
erstmal so 20, 30 Jahre lang alle umgepflügt hat.
So was wie, wir sollten immer nur auf einer Seite fahren und so.
Da kam dann wieder diese Mana, dieses ewige Risiko, nein, wir fahren nur auf
einer Seite. Das ist endlich ein Fahrzeug, das auf jeder Seite fahren kann.
Naja, schwierige Diskussion, aber muss geführt werden.
Ja ich fand's auf jeden Fall mal, also ich fand die Kommentare sehr schön,
was sich da, gab natürlich noch sehr viel mehr, ich hab jetzt mal hier ein paar
exemplarisch rausgewählt.
Ich würde aber trotzdem nochmal in Erinnerung rufen wollen, dass wir gar nicht sagen,
diese Technologie wird jetzt irgendwie folgenlos bleiben und lass mal laufen
und gib geile Bilder bei Midjourney,
aber es ist schon relativ klar,
dass jetzt erstmal diese Technologie Ich würde jetzt mal vorsichtig sagen,
sehr faszinierende Möglichkeiten bietet, vieles im Leben erstmal zu vereinfachen.
Dass die am Ende wieder bei den Reichen landet,
die damit die Weltherrschaft und ihren Geldstapel ausweiten,
da bin ich mir auch sicher, aber genau aus dem Grund würde ich sagen,
lasst uns mal wenigstens alle benutzen.
Weil sonst haben wir noch weniger davon.
So und dann schauen wir uns nachher, also wir sagen nicht,
dass wir irgendwie Regulierungen und sowas irgendwie ablehnen wollen,
aber wenn, dann wäre schon mal ein klarer, argumentierbarer Fall,
wäre nicht schlecht und dann, das würde ich halt eher in Einzelfällen sehen
oder in einzelnen Bereichen,
die man dann mal diskutieren muss, aber im Moment ist mir das zu sehr gelenkt
von Leuten, die zu wenig von dieser Technologie verstanden haben.
Wäre jetzt mal meine vorsichtige Einschätzung.
Und wahrscheinlich haben die Leute, die viel von dieser Technologie verstanden
haben, die haben jetzt irgendwie keinen Bock, sich das am Ende regulieren zu lassen.
Die, die die Risiken einschätzen wollen, müssen jetzt halt erstmal besser werden.
Oder müssen gut werden da drin.
Die Risiken zu verstehen und dann ordentlich auszudrücken und dann auch ihnen
zielgerichtet entgegentreten zu können.
Es wird auf jeden Fall sehr schwierig werden, die nächste Zeit,
weil die Entwicklungen laufen in einer Geschwindigkeit gerade voran.
Also ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, wann wir da überhaupt mal eine Verschnaufpause
einlegen werden können.
Wird kommen, aber gerade befruchtet sich das Thema gegenseitig viel zu sehr.
Also was allein durch die ganzen Kombinationen dieser ganzen Systeme derzeit
an Optimierung geschaffen wird. Und wie sozusagen schon so Second Level,
Third Level lernende Systeme, die auf lernenden Systemen basieren.
Selbst in der Lage sind sich Dinge auszudenken. Also wir sind ja schon bei den
moderneren KIs schon so weit,
sodass die quasi, ich sag mal salopp, selbst auf Ideen kommen,
was man mal machen könnte.
Und da wird's dann halt schon wirklich sportlich.
Das wird sich nicht nur in Text ausdrücken, das wird sich auch in Bild und Ton natürlich ausdrücken.
Jetzt haben wir ja schon diese Bilderzeugung, wir haben auch schon die Videoerzeugung,
da dauert es dann nicht mehr so lange, dann haben wir auch sozusagen die Storyerzeugung,
dann können ganze Hollywoodfilme quasi da mal rausfallen.
Also das wird jetzt nicht nächste Woche soweit sein, aber so perspektivisch sind das Dinge,
die stattfinden gerade und die uns noch vor ganz andere Fragestellungen stellen
werden, aber werden auf dem Weg halt auch eine ganze Menge positive Entwicklungen
haben, zwangsläufig. Medizin sei da mal wirklich genannt.
Wirklich ein Feld, was unter diesem klassischen Problem, was Deep Learning ganz
gut zu lösen scheint, ja sehr leidet. Es gibt da sehr viel Daten,
die man betrachten kann, die sind aber alle sehr fuzzy.
Man muss aufwändige Studien machen, um irgendwas herauszufinden,
aber in dem Moment, wo man diese ganze Datensammlung und Betrachtung und Auswertung
gut automatisiert bekommt,
Stichwort Smartphones, die Gesundheitsdaten, idealerweise natürlich anonymisiert,
liefern, dann kann man hier unter Umständen sehr schnell Fortschritte machen.
Diese modernen SWAT-Watches sind in der Lage, aus einer Langzeit- und Detailbeobachtung
des Pulses schon Warnungen herauszugeben, wie es dem Herzen so geht.
Und wir werden da sicherlich noch ganz andere Erkenntnisse haben.
Und damit bin ich noch nicht mal bei der Genforschung, die bestimmt jetzt ein
richtiges fest feiert, weil natürlich die Komplexität der genetischen Struktur
ist ja quasi der heilige Gral und da hatten wir schon letztes Jahr den großen Durchbruch.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das Google System nochmal heißt. Hast du das vielleicht
im Kopf, mit dem sie diese Problematik der Proteinfaltung ja schon gelöst haben?
Hatten wir vor zwei Sendungen hier erwähnt. Mir fällt es gerade auch nicht mehr ein.
Genau, also das sind sozusagen Schlüsselentdeckungen, die im Prinzip komplett
neue medizinische Behandlungsmethoden eröffnen und das ist alles extrem vielversprechend.
Ob es letzten Endes… Alpha Fold. Ja genau, also aus dieser Alpha-Serie wieder wie AlphaGo.
Also ob es am Ende eigentlich so sinnvoll ist, dem Menschen ewiges Leben zu
geben, da habe ich so meine Zweifel.
Aber wir müssen damit rechnen, dass wir das Problem auch noch kriegen.
Das ist natürlich schwierig ne.
Und dann haben wir auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge neue Probleme.
Ja da bist du ja deine alten Nilos. Uah uah uah uah großoma nervt wieder total.
Ja, aber das wird ja dann erstmal, nur für das Problem werden dann erstmal die
reichen haben. Da mache ich mir nicht so große Sorgen, dass ich das Problem
noch habe. Mit dem ewigen Leben.
Für uns reicht es nicht mehr. Höchste Strafe. Für uns reicht es leider nicht mehr.
Nee ich bin ganz, also so scheiße der Tod ist aber dauerhaft will ich das hier
auch nicht mitmachen. Ganz ehrlich.
Ich könnte noch eine Weile.
Ja eine Weile schon aber weißt du irgendwann ist es auch gut.
Ich hab ja die These rausgehauen, dass meine Podcasts auch noch in 500 Jahren
gehört werden und ich würde das eigentlich ganz gerne überprüfen.
Also ihr, die ihr jetzt diesen Podcast in 500 Jahren hört, jetzt ist es 2023, 2523
wenn ihr diesen Podcast hört, hoffe ich,
dass ihr Zeitreise schon erfunden habt und gebt mir mal ein Zeichen,
okay war kein Zeichen, entweder werden die nicht 500 Jahre lang gehört oder
die kriegen das mit der Zeitmaschinen nicht hin.
Den, das hat doch schon Stephen Hawking irgendwann in den 70er gemacht.
Hat auch schon nicht geklappt, da war sie auch noch nicht erfunden.
Dauert noch ein bisschen. Die Zukunft muss ja auch erst noch passieren, weißt du?
Ach ja.
Der Zeitstrahl muss erst noch da hinkommen. Okay, wir haben dann noch einen
Kommentar gehabt zu Microtargeting durch Ilva Johansson, dazu kommentierte David.
Und um den Punkt mit dem Micro-Targeting von Frau Johansson noch mal etwas konkreter zu machen,
weil es oft so abstrakt behandelt wird, die zuständige Kommissarin hat Werbung
für ihr Projekt gezielt in Ländern ausspielen lassen,
die im Rat aktuell dagegenstehen und unter Bevölkerungsgruppen,
bei denen sie sich besonders viel Zuspruch zu ihren Argumenten verspricht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Propaganda hier noch der richtige Begriff ist,
aber das sollte sich schon als sehr gezielter Versuch lesen lassen,
den aktuellen politischen Prozess durch Einfluss auf die nationalen Wählergruppen zu beeinflussen.
Ja, gut, dass du das nochmal klargestellt hast und es ist wirklich faszinierend, oder?
Ich weiß nicht ob faszinierend das erste Wort ist, was mir da einfallen würde, aber Frechheit ist das.
Ja unverschämt.
Ja soll sich mal was schämen.
Ja macht's aber nicht. Ja.
Noch schlimmer.
Und jetzt, ja das finde ich zum Beispiel auch ärgerlich ne.
Kriegt den du du du du du Orden von Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Nee, da müssen wir uns mal was überlegen, was soll der verleihen.
So, jetzt kommen wir endlich zu ein paar Anmeldungen. Es gibt gar nicht so viel.
Ihr merkt das vielleicht daran, dass wir uns auch so lange an dem schönen Feedback
aufgehalten haben und da auch mit euch die Diskussion ein bisschen weitergeführt
haben. Ich hoffe, das war nochmal fruchtbar.
Wichtig auch.
Wichtig, ne?
Ja.
Und jetzt haben wir, wir haben ja hier darüber gesprochen,
dass es gegen Google gerade einen Wettbewerbsprozess gibt,
der also über Ausnutzen der marktbeherrschenden Stellung und auch das gezielte
Herbeiführen und so weiter handelt und da gab es jetzt eine dann doch interessante
Meldung und zwar bezahlt Google, so viel war ja bekannt,
Geld dafür, die Standardsuchmaschine auf Smartphones und in Webbrowsern zu sein.
Man wusste aber nicht genau, wie viel.
Und wir haben auch darüber gesprochen, dass Google sich ja, das zum Beispiel
auch über Android eher zwingt,
dass die Google-Apps da drauf sind, also alles dieses Ausnutzen einer marktbeherrschenden
Stellung, da gab es häufig, gab es heute das ein oder andere Kommentar zu.
Das Kartellrecht verbietet dir nicht eine marktbeherrschende Stellung zu haben.
Ja, das darfst du. Du darfst sie nur nicht ausnutzen.
Und hier die Überlegung, wenn jetzt jemand eine marktbeherrschende Stellung
hat und die wird dieses Unternehmen natürlich sehr viel tun, um die zu zementieren.
Zum Beispiel sehr viel Geld dafür ausgeben, die Nummer eins in den Browsern zu sein,
also die voreingestellte Suchmaschine und dafür hat Google im Jahr 2021 insgesamt
26 Milliarden US-Dollar ausgegeben.
Es gibt nicht so viele Browser, Google, Chrome machen sie selber,
es gibt Firefox, es gibt Safari, es gibt Edge von Microsoft, das war's dann.
Und ja, die haben also hier, diesen Betrag geben sie aus und es ist der größte
einzelne Ausgabeposten des Unternehmens überhaupt.
Der hat sich seit 2014 damit mehr
als verdreifacht, da war er also noch im einstelligen Milliarden-Bereich.
Was also auch bedeutet, dass sie halt quasi immer mehr Geld ausgeben,
um sich Konkurrenz vom Leid zu halten.
Diese Zahlen wollten sie natürlich ungern veröffentlichen, weil das ihre zukünftige
Verhandlungsposition beeinträchtigt.
Klar, wenn du jetzt irgendwie Firefox bist und sagst ja scheiße ey,
die geben 26 Milliarden aus und wir haben 5.
Oder du bist Apple und denkst dir so, wir kriegen 21 aber die geben 26 aus, da geht noch was.
Ist das natürlich für Google nicht von Vorteil, aber hättest du gedacht,
dass die so viel Geld dafür ausgeben?
Mir war schon länger klar, dass das sehr viel Geld ist, was sie da ausgeben.
Also Apple äußert sich zwar nicht dazu, was sie bekommen, aber es wird schon
länger gemunkelt, dass es sich dabei um einen extrem hohen Betrag handelt.
Wenn man mal davon ausgeht, dass Google selbst mit seinen eigenen Betriebssystemen
gut so zwei Drittel des Marktes vielleicht abdeckt,
kannst du davon ausgehen, also das restliche Drittel geht halt an die anderen
und von die anderen ist halt Apple relativ viel.
Also kannst du davon ausgehen, dass von diesen 26 Milliarden ein Großteil bei Apple hängen bleibt.
Und es wird schon länger gemunkelt, dass das der größte Einnahmeposten bei Apple Services ist.
Schon irre, ne? Aber das, ich mach jetzt nicht nochmal die Diskussion auf,
dass das Unternehmen sich durch Innovation und so weiter oben hält,
aber die 26 Milliarden die einfach nur verpuffen dafür, dass kein anderer in
den Browsern die Standardsuchmaschine ist, das ist schon...
Ich weiß nicht ob ich das so verwerflich finde um ehrlich zu sein.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass es verwerflich ist. Ich rede überhaupt nicht von verwerflich.
Wir treffen hier keine moralischen Urteile, aber es hat nichts mit verwerflich
zu tun, es hat einfach nur etwas damit zu tun, dass das Unternehmen,
offenbar seine marktbeherrschende Position nicht unbedingt dadurch aufrecht
erhält, das überzeugendste Produkt zu sein.
Wenn du das überzeugendste Produkt bist, dann brauchst du nicht 26 Milliarden
dafür auszugeben, dass bloß niemand irgendwo als Default deine Konkurrenz wird.
Es ist eigentlich ein Urteil, oder ich würde diese 26 Milliarden als eine große
Anerkennung Anerkennung für die Qualität anderer Suchmaschinen werten,
weil die zahlen ja nicht eine Milliarde, die zahlen ja, also das ist ja quasi
das, was sie wahrscheinlich ausgeben müssen, um andere Suchmaschinen zu überbieten.
Die zahlen ja nicht freiwillig so viel.
Ja, beziehungsweise um die Betriebssystemhersteller dazu zu bringen,
sie als default einzustellen, das kann ihnen ja eigentlich egal sein,
nur in dem Moment, wo sie natürlich dafür Geld bekommen müssen,
das sind Werbungskosten, die sie gerne einnehmen.
Und Google kann natürlich am meisten zahlen. Da sieht man aber auch mal was
das wert ist. Diese Suchzeile. Was das für eine Power hat.
Das ist nochmal der Einstieg in das Internet.
Ich erinnere mich noch an so eine Straßenumfrage in den USA,
das ist auch schon ein paar Jahre her, wo die Leute, ich weiß nicht mehr genau
was die Frage war, aber aus den Antworten konntest du halt irgendwie herausfinden,
dass für die Google irgendwie sozusagen der Anfang vom Internet ist.
Der Browser, der sich öffnet ist Google.
Es war mal ein Sendungstitel bei Logo Netzpolitik, der Anfang vom Internet.
Der Anfang vom Ende oder?
Der Anfang vom Ende.
So hieß die Sendung? Echt?
Bin ich mir relativ sicher.
Wirklich? Ich kann mich gar nicht dran erinnern. Aber wir haben auch schon so
viele Sendungen gemacht. 474.
Es gibt einen anderen Anfang vom Internet, du kannst ja nochmal kurz gucken
ob der stimmt, ich meine ich hätte alle Sendungstitel im Kopf.
Also es gibt eine Sendung, endlich sind wir am Anfang angekommen,
dann gibt es am Anfang vom Ende der ersten Welle und das sind die beiden mit Anfang.
Ach schade, da hast du die gelöscht.
Es gibt ja noch einen anderen Anfang vom Internet und das ist,
war Facebook, überhaupt das mit diesem Anfang vom Internet ist ja auch so eine Sache,
Anfang vom Internet gibt's ja eigentlich nur bei so Leuten, wo man noch von
Internet redet, man redet ja in zunehmendem Maße gar nicht mehr vom Internet.
Sondern? Apps. Stimmt.
Und da gibt es natürlich noch, da gibt es eben Facebook.
Und die, wie wir uns erinnern, verdienen ja auch sehr, sehr viel Geld.
Und womit verdienen die ihr Geld? Ha, wir haben denen niemals Geld gegeben.
Also kriegen sie es für Werbung. Und nämlich für genau diese personalisierte,
zielgerichtete Werbung, die Eva Johansen da geschaltet hat, wo wir uns gerade
noch drüber echauffiert haben.
Das ist das Geschäftsmodell von Facebook. Die haben kein anderes.
Haben sie nicht. Doch, ich meine, die verkaufen diese Brillen oder so,
um einem da dann irgendwie Werbung einzublenden.
Aber es ist relativ klar, Facebook ist ein Milliardenunternehmen,
dessen Geschäftsmodell de facto Verhaltensmanipulation ist. Klingt schlimm,
aber Werbung ist halt versuchte Verhaltensmanipulation.
Wer das besser macht, ist halt besser und kriegt mehr Geld dafür.
Es bietet aber Facebook ja in die andere Richtung eine faszinierende Dienstleistung an,
wo es unsere persönlichen Beziehungen und Interessen und so weiter quasi einsammelt
und uns den Kontakt zu unseren Freunden, Familien und so weiter gibt.
Und diese Dienstleistung können wir in Anspruch nehmen, müssen wir nur irgendwie
so ungefähr ein Wissen von ChatGPT1 lesen und dem zustimmen oder wie viele Seiten
auf jeden Fall die Datenschutzerklärung ist, die natürlich keine Sau versteht
und so weiter und so weiter.
Und jetzt verlangt aber die Datenschutzgrundverordnung, dass man einwilligen muss.
Wenn man oder dass man die Einwilligung der NutzerInnen haben muss,
wenn man ihre persönlichen Daten für Werbezwecke verarbeiten will.
Das ist ja auch wirklich so eine, kann man wirklich sagen,
so jetzt ohne Angst der Überregulation, kann man sagen,
das ist zumindest so eine Minimalkonsens-Sache des Anstands,
dass man sagt, wenn wir deine, wenn wir alles, was wir hier von dir sammeln,
für Werbung verwenden, dann wäre es gut, wenn du dazu Ja sagst.
Oder wenn wir dir die Gelegenheit geben, dazu Nein zu sagen oder dich überhaupt
darüber in Kenntnis setzen und du sagst, habe ich gelesen.
All das passiert aber nicht, weil da sagt Facebook dann, ja,
das ist ja integraler Bestandteil unserer Dienstleistung und deswegen müssen
wir da nicht nachfragen.
So. Und wenn du so Facebook-Anwälte hast, dann kannst du natürlich relativ lange sowas streiten.
Und jetzt hat sich.
Der Europäische Datenschutzausschuss beschlossen, dass Irland jetzt bitte Facebook
wegen anhaltender Verstöße gegen die DSGVO diese Praxis, also das Nutzen von
persönlichen Daten ohne Einwilligung zu verbieten.
Die sagen also, das was ihr macht ist nicht mit der DSGVO vereinbar,
damit ihr diese Daten verwenden dürft, braucht ihr eine Rechtsgrundlage,
die gibt es nur mit informierten und freiwilliger Einwilligung und die habt ihr nicht.
Und was ihr macht, ihr wähnt die Datensammlung und deren Zusammenführung in
den AGBs, das reicht aber nicht aus.
Und interessanterweise geht das auf Norwegen zurück,
die sind zwar nicht in der EU, aber im europäischen Wirtschaftsraum und wenden
daher die DSGVO an und jetzt sagen die also,
passt auf, Norwegen hat das lokal auch schon gemacht, die haben im Juli Meta
vorübergehend verboten Werbung zu schalten, die auf Nutzerverhalten basiert und Profilen.
Ja, dann wurde das noch mal bestätigt im September und jetzt sollen also das
auf EU-Ebene gemacht werden.
So, und jetzt, pass auf, was macht Facebook? Und das ist eigentlich lustig,
weil es total vorhersehbar ist.
Die machen den gleichen Trick, wie die ganzen anderen werbefinanzierten Seiten,
die es sich nicht leisten konnten, so lange auf der Ebene mit den Datenschutzbehörden zu zanken.
Nämlich die sagen, alles klar, dann gibt es jetzt halt ein überteuertes Bezahlangebot.
Kostet jetzt 50 Euro oder was?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Ich hätte jetzt an 10er gedacht,
aber ich weiß gar nicht genau, ob ich den Preis jetzt irgendwo gelesen habe.
9,99€. Ja, Schnäppchen.
Facebook ohne Werbung.
Instagram und Facebook, da kannst du sogar beides oder was? Da musst du jeden extra bezahlen.
Ab November müssen Nutzer demnach mindestens 9,99€ bezahlen,
wenn sie keine Werbung über Facebook und Instagram sehen wollen.
Wer personalisierte Anzeigen akzeptiert, kann die Netzwerke weiterhin gratis nutzen.
Und das ist ja genau das, was wir auch die Justiziare von den Verlagen sagen.
Und was ja auch der Max Schrems mit Neub regelmäßig da bekämpft und gegenklagt,
dass dieses, hier es gibt ein Pur-Abo, dass das de facto einfach nur ein Trick
ist, um diese Einwilligung zu bekommen.
Zum Beispiel hatte er ja auch mitgenommen oder mit angefügt,
dass das so ungefähr das einzige Abo ist, was es gibt, was sich nicht automatisch
verlängert, was schon so ungefähr zeigt, weißt du.
Und ich hab halt auch schon mit dem einen oder anderen Justiziar von einer,
von Verlagten gesprochen, die also
sagen, ja klar, das ist jetzt nicht ein Geschäftsmodell oder Profitcenter.
Dieser Dialog ist nicht darauf ausgelegt, dass du jetzt da die 2,99,
3,99, 9,99 oder was auch immer das kosten soll zahlst.
Sondern es ist darauf ausgelegt, dass du sagst, nee, dann lieber gratis mit Werbung. Klar, ja.
Und das macht also jetzt Facebook auch.
Bin mal gespannt.
Also, ja, die Frage ist ja, mehrere Fragen,
also erstmal gibt es, ich nehme mal an es gibt auch schon irgendwie den einen
oder anderen Dienst, wo du dafür bezahlst keine Werbung zu sehen oder?
Um die zu nutzen?
Ach doch, klar. Ich hab einen kostenpflichtigen Werbeblocker.
Den bezahl ich. Okay. Ja, nee.
Ne, das Problem ist ja, nur um das kurz zu sortieren, ich zahl für eine ganze Menge Dienste.
Aber wenn ich hier, was weiß ich, nehmen wir mal unsere Freunde vom Spiegel
Verlag Rudolf Augstein KG.
Nur weil man denen 30 Euro im Monat zahlt, heißt das ja nicht,
dass sie die Werbung wegmachen.
Führt das normale Abo den Zugriff auf die zusätzlichen Artikel?
Ja.
Aber es gibt noch eine Ordnung.
Da muss man nochmal extra einwerfen.
Naja, weil das ist natürlich, du schneidest damit eine Verdienstquelle ab,
die halt sehr lukrativ ist.
Das mag ja sein. Trotzdem ist ja der, also das glaube ich haben wir ja alle verstanden,
ich finde es trotzdem äußerst ärgerlich,
dass man das nicht auch noch weglässt und dann wollen sie da noch mehr haben.
Ich kann jetzt hier mal gucken, was kostet das denn hier?
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall lustig, das Abo, dass du sagst,
ich möchte Spiegel Plus oder so, das wird dir überall angeboten,
aber wenn du einmal gesagt hast, ich nehme eure Werbung, dann musst du wirklich
suchen, um das zu finden.
Also die wollen werbefrei lesen, kostet, wenn du kein Spiegel Plus hast,
also sogar nur die Gratisbeiträge ohne Werbung kostet ein Euro pro Woche.
Und wenn du jetzt Spiegel Abonnent bist,
Spiegel Plus, dann als Upgrade 50 Cent pro Woche,
also irgendwie 25 Euro im Jahr ungefähr und werbefrei Spiegel Plus kostet 5,50 Euro pro Woche.
Woche.
Das ist jetzt einmal alles. Also da hast du dann ohne Anzeigen,
Pop-Ups und andere Werbeformate keine Weitergabe ihrer Daten an Werbetreibende.
Alle Spiegel plus Inhalte inklusive Newsletter und ePaper 5,50 die Woche. 5,48 Euro.
Da jetzt die Frage, wie empfinden wir das?
Also 285 Euro im Jahr.
Also ich hab ja, benutzt du zum Beispiel YouTube Premium?
Ja, ich bin doch nicht bescheuert. Nein. Warum? Mach ich nicht,
ich bezahle doch nicht YouTube.
Warum nicht?
Ne, nein. Nein. Kannst vergessen, auf gar keinen Fall. Niemals.
Weil?
Weil ich für mein Geld arbeiten gehe Tim und ich gebe das doch nicht irgendwie
für so eine Scheiße aus. Also sorry.
Ich weiß ja nicht, ob du da ab und zu mal vorbeischaust auf dieser Webseite,
aber ich tue das eine ganze Menge, also ich bin wirklich heavy User,
ich benutze YouTube mehr als jeden Fernsehkanal in Deutschland.
Ich habe auch keinen Fernseher insofern.
Aber du weißt ja auch, was man für Fernsehen sozusagen bezahlt.
Gut da kriegst du dann trotzdem noch die Werbung um die Ohren.
Aber so krieg ich halt für einen halbwegs definierten Preis nahezu jeden relevanten Videocontent.
Also nahezu natürlich nicht alles, aber schon sehr viel.
Und hab überhaupt gar keine Werbung. Ist okay.
Also es ist schwierig jetzt sozusagen diesen Diensten vorzuwerfen,
dass sie unangemessen teuer sind, weil am Ende ist es ja auch eine Frage,
was ist dir sozusagen die Werbefreiheit auch wert.
Werbung sehen und die Daten, die eigenen Daten analysiert und weitergeleitet
zu sehen, das sind aber auch nochmal zwei Paar Schuhe, ja ich hätte ja, wir haben,
so ein bisschen auch die Nerd Perspektive, ich glaube das hatten wir auch schon mal erwähnt,
es gibt so dieses so, oh mein Gott, ihr wollt mir jetzt Werbung zustellen,
die voll auf mich zugeschnitten ist, weil sie mein Profil interpretiert und
dann genau weiß, was ich jetzt vielleicht als nächstes kaufen möchte.
Da gibt's Leute, die sind begeistert davon.
Ja gut, aber sorry Tim, das ist jetzt irgendwie so 80s oder irgendwie Anfang 2000er Diskussion.
Wir haben ja inzwischen sind wir ein bisschen weiter, als dass Leute sich freuen,
dass sie die richtige Werbung bekommen.
Also wir haben ja jetzt dann durchaus doch, als auch als Gesellschaft langsam
verstanden, dass sich dadurch weitreichende Manipulationsmöglichkeiten ergeben,
die auch Anwendungen finden.
Ja und es ist nicht nur, klar es mag eine ganze Reihe Menschen geben,
wo das Beste, was man aus denen rauskriegt ist, die dazu zu bringen irgendeine
Scheiße zu kaufen, aber es gibt eben auch noch politische Themen und Sachverhalte.
Auch, ich mein, wenn du, wenn du, also ein...
Eine Möglichkeit, also ich kann dir mal, wenn ich mal auf YouTube gehe,
was ich nicht so häufig mache, ja, also ich gucke auch mal was auf YouTube an,
dann kommt da halt irgendwelche Scammer Werbung von irgendwelchen Leuten,
die mit irgendwelchen Get rich quick Schemes die Leute abziehen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich hast du, also wenn du stattdessen 10 Euro im Monat zahlst dafür,
dass dir diese Werbung nicht kommt, dann gibt's halt Leute,
die haben diese 10 Euro nicht, die fallen dann auf diese Get-Rich-Quick-Schemes
rein und zahlen so ihre Strafe,
aber ey, also irgendwie YouTube ist für mich einfach nur ein Video-Hoster,
es tut mir leid und ich, wir haben auch hier darüber gesprochen,
dass du, du fandst ja auch YouTube innovativ, ich find's nicht innovativ,
Aber ich bin auf jeden Fall nicht bereit für deren Dienstleistungen Geld auszugeben.
Ich meine man kann ja auch Werbung und Tracking auch nochmal separat betrachten,
das war eigentlich so ein bisschen mein Argument.
Jaja, das kann man aber nicht, weil in dem Moment, wo die Werbung nicht mehr
zielgerechtet ist, ist sie halt absolut wehrenlos.
Also die Neuens für dich ist potenziell die gleiche, aber die Leute,
die die Werbung schalten, schalten die Werbung ja, weil sie zielgerichtet ist.
Nicht weil sie sagen, voll geil, da haben wir Werbung.
Und wir haben ja vor kurzem auch noch darüber gesprochen, dass genau diese Art
der Werbung jetzt in unser schönes Podcast-Gallien Einzug erhält.
Wo eben die wenigen großen Podcasts oder wo es nur noch wenige große Podcasts
gibt, die sich versuchen eigene Kundenstämme und direkte Werbebeziehungen zu erhalten.
Und die jetzt auch merken, dass es denen langsam an den Kragen geht,
weil große Plattformen ihre Plattformen macht da ausnutzen und jetzt eben die
Leute zum Schalten von Werbung nicht zu ATP gehen,
sondern zu Spotify.
Und das wird auch so weitergehen, das wird auch diesen ganzen US-Podcast dann
früher oder später an den Kragen gehen.
Bekannte deutsche Podcast sind ja direkt zu Werbevermarktern gegangen.
Was machen wir jetzt, wenn Facebook sagt, naja, also wenn ihr nicht hier zu
der Werbung ja sagt und wenn ihr nicht unser Bezahl-Abo habt,
dann gibt's für euch kein Facebook. Meinst du, das machen sie?
Nee, das ist ja genau der Punkt, dass sie, ja doch klar,
das machen die, ja klar, ist dir doch völlig egal, es ist doch klar,
dass alle sofort sagen, willst du Facebook gratis mit Werbung oder willst du 10er bezahlen?
Meinst du, also den Menschen möchte ich sehen, der dann sagt,
voll geil, endlich kann ich für die Dienstleistung von Facebook bezahlen und
endlich kann ich meinen Datenschutzgrundgedanken,
der mich hier seit vielen Jahren plagt auf dieser Seite, endlich mal zum Ausdruck
bringen und sagen, jetzt bin ich glücklich, ihr kriegt dann noch einen Zehner,
das wird einfach nicht passieren.
Also es ist doch einfach nur ein Einverständnissammelangebot.
Wahrscheinlich kannst du Facebook am meisten damit ärgern, wenn du sagst,
okay, ich mach das jetzt, ich überweise euch jetzt monatlich einen Zehner,
viel Spaß mit der Buchführung.
Meine Frage war eigentlich eher, also sagen wir mal die Europäische Union setzt
sich jetzt hier durch und beschließt sozusagen,
dass Facebook muss die quasi die kostenlose Nutzung ohne Tracking erlauben.
Wobei kostenlos können sie ja nicht sagen, aber Facebook müsste sich dann sozusagen
entscheiden, nehmen wir von diesen Personen dann Geld?
Also gibt es sozusagen… Das hat Facebook sich ja schon entschieden.
Also das ist angekündigt, dass sie das tun werden.
Dass sie Geld, dass sie ein Bezahl-Dings haben. Aber die Frage ist,
haben sie auch schon angekündigt, dass sie sagen, ja, du kannst auch alles ablehnen.
Ohne zu bezahlen.
Nein, das brauchst du ja nicht. Also guck mal, in dem Moment,
wo sie, also von der, also rechtlich müssen sie dein Einverständnis für die
Nutzung dieser Daten zu Werbezwecken und die Weitergabe und so weiter alles haben, ja.
Und streng genommen ist es so, dass sie sich dieses Einverständnis gerade gar
nicht wirklich holen. Zumindest nicht explizit und informiert.
Die sagen nur steht in den AGB.
Und jetzt wären sie in dem Moment konform, wo sie sich dieses Einverständnis von allen holen würden.
Also sie müssen juristisch durch den Schritt mit all ihren Milliarden NutzerInnen,
wahrscheinlich hunderte Millionen NutzerInnen in der EU.
Dass die sagen, ja, ich erlaube euch meine Daten zu Werbezwecken zu nutzen.
So, jetzt hat Facebook eh nicht den besten Rufersdatenschutz und so weiter angeht
und da müssen die jetzt einmal durch.
Und der einfachste Weg dahin zu kommen, ist für die einfach zu sagen,
ey, möchtest du bezahlen oder weiterhin kostenlos?
Ja, dann sagst du kostenlos. Dann sag ich, ja dann übrigens dann kommt hier Werbung und so, ne?
Und wir geben mal einen Werbepartner und so. Dann sagen die Leute,
ja, okay, war ja schon immer so. Alles klar, fertig, weiter geht's.
Und das ist halt der einfachste Weg, dieses Einverständnis zu sammeln,
ist einfach die Alternative einfach mit Geld zu belasten.
Deswegen machen die das mit diesem kostenpflichtigen Angebot.
Außerdem dient das kostenpflichtige Angebot dem Zweck, dass sie dann sagen können,
wir haben ja ein alternatives Angebot und wir zwingen den Leuten die Werbung nicht auf.
Die können ja sagen, sie möchten die nicht haben. Und deswegen haben sie eine
informierte Entscheidung getroffen.
Wenn sie das nicht machen, kann aber auch nicht die EU sagen,
naja du musst das jetzt kostenlos anbieten.
Du kannst ja nicht einfach Leuten sagen, du musst eine Dienstleistung anbieten ohne Geschäftsmodell.
Das machen die ja auch nicht. Die sagen, de facto sagt die Europäische Union
oder wollen diese Datenschützer sagen, so wie du das machst darfst du es nicht
und dann darfst du die ganze Dienstleistung nicht mehr anbieten.
So und was passiert dann? So wenn Facebook sozusagen wirklich diese Frage dann
fragen muss und wenn ich nein sage, sagen sie dann, okay dann darfst du jetzt
hier nichts mehr benutzen.
Du kannst ja nicht nein sagen.
Wieso kann ich nicht nein sagen? Das ist ja hypothetisch. Sagen wir mal es wäre so.
Ich logge mich ein und Facebook sagt, ach übrigens, wolltest du eigentlich getrackt
werden oder nicht? Ja? Sag ich nö.
Was sagt Facebook dann? Sagt sie so, okay.
Das ist aber nicht die Frage, die sie dir stellen.
Das Wort hypothetisch. Angenommen man würde sie jetzt rechtlich dazu bringen,
dass sie diese Frage stellen.
Und würde es dann überhaupt statthaft sein, dass man komplett außen vor sein
darf? Also ist das Ausschließen der Benutzer sozusagen zulässig?
Okay, also du meinst ob man Facebook zwingen könnte, die Dienstleistung kostenlos anzubieten.
Und das ist natürlich nicht so.
Ja, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Also genau deswegen machen sie das ja jetzt. Sie werden im Prinzip einfach sagen,
du kannst unseren Dienst sonst nicht nutzen.
Und dann kommen sie natürlich in gefährliches Eis und deswegen haben alle anderen
genau diesen Trick gemacht mit dem, naja okay, du musst das nicht machen.
Wir zwingen dich ja gar nicht dazu. Du kannst ja gerne uns Geld geben,
dann machen wir das nicht.
Und das scheint mir der juristische Trick zu sein, um das zu schaffen.
Ich glaube, sonst bist du in der Situation, in der sie jetzt sind,
wo sie dir de facto die Möglichkeit nicht geben.
Also sicherlich kann nicht die Europäische Union sagen, naja hier,
die Dienstleistung, die ihr da macht, mit der ihr Milliarden verdient nebenher,
die müsst ihr jetzt einfach ohne Geschäftsmodell weiterhin anbieten,
dazu verpflichten wir euch. Das kann ja auch nicht gehen.
Das heißt, das Verlangen ist, man braucht eine informierte Zustimmung.
Und was im Moment passiert ist, Facebook hat die nicht und zahlt alle paar Monate
mal ein paar Millionen Euro Strafe. Ich glaube die letzte Strafe,
die sie gezahlt haben, waren irgendwo 300 Millionen oder so.
Anfang des Jahres in Irland, ja. 390 Millionen Euro Bußgeld,
weil Meta die Daten zu Werbezwecken unzulässig genutzt hat.
Das sind so die sprichwörtlichen Portokasse.
Genau, aber natürlich kann man, also wenn die Europäische Union das Geschäftsmodell verbieten würde,
also das geht ja nicht, ist ja klar, dass man Facebook nur zu einer legal compliance zwingen kann,
zur Einhaltung der Gesetze, Aber man kann sich ja nicht dazu zwingen zu sagen,
du musst diese Dienstleistung den Leuten anbieten.
Es ist ja noch viel schlimmer, die Leute haben ja die AGBs auch akzeptiert.
Es ist nur, dass nach einer neuen Regelung diese Zustimmung explizit erteilt sein muss.
Es gibt ja eine Kostenvariante, ist eben der elegante Teil.
Fast zu schockierend, wie einfach sich dann auch so ein gesetzlicher Anspruch dann umgehen lässt.
Die schreiben einfach an die Nein, die machen im Prinzip an den Nein Button ein Preisschild dran.
Ja so kann man das sehen.
Und schon sagen alle ja.
Ja ich bin gespannt wie lange sich das noch halten kann, weil es gibt schon
so ein bisschen so einen Trend zu Bezahldiensten und grundsätzlich finde ich
das auch nicht unbedingt verwerflich.
Gab's schon so einige Dienste, wo ich mir gewünscht hätte, sie hätten einen
ordentlichen Bezahldienst eingeführt. Twitter zum Beispiel.
Aber, naja, aber keinen ordentlichen. Vor allem haben sie kein Twitter mehr
im Angebot. Nur noch Twix.
Ja, also da stimme ich dir auch zu, dass ich das...
Ich zahle ja für durchaus einiges im Internet.
Ich habe aber dann schon auch den Anspruch, dass es dann keine Werbung mehr
gibt und deswegen ärgere ich mich zum Beispiel, dass das bei Verlagen eben schon
so lange das ständige Geschäftsmodell ist.
Ich habe auch zum Beispiel, betrachte ich das erstmal als halbwegs positiv,
dass das Software jetzt eben as a service immer mehr oder als Abonnement bereitgestellt wird.
Das heißt, es gibt einfach eine bessere Sicherheit für die Entwickler,
einen dauerhaften Income Stream dafür,
sie können die Zufriedenheit mit ihrer Software relativ schnell messen,
sie haben skalierende Effekte, sie haben niedrigere Einstiegshürden in ihre
Dienstleistung, Adobe ist da natürlich ein super Beispiel.
Früher musstest du dir irgendwie auf schwierige Weise Creative Suite Cracks
irgendwie holen, um diese paar tausend Euro Software zu nutzen.
Heute kannst du dir die für, wenn du es mal wirklich brauchst,
für 60 Euro im Monat oder so klicken.
Oder lässt dir irgendwie so ein Photoshop Abo für einen Zehner laufen.
Das ist schon ganz in Ordnung mit Bezahlmodellen, ja.
Da bin ich schon insgesamt ein Freund von, aber ich glaube nicht,
dass Facebook, da muss man vielleicht einen Unterschied machen zwischen,
jetzt sagen wir mal, nehmen wir jetzt mal Mid Journey, irgendein Discord Ding,
die nehmen glaube ich, weiß nicht, was ich da jetzt bezahlt habe,
für einen Monat 10, 12 Euro, das werden die im Zweifelsfall bei meiner Nutzung,
werden sie an mir Geld verdienen, weil ich das jetzt nicht so oft in Anspruch
nehme, ich gucke mir da auch eher gerade an, was die anderen Leute sich da so
malen lassen. Und die haben...
Die kommen ja nicht so aus dieser massenhaft Verhaltensammel-Geschäftsmodell-Ecke.
Ich glaube, wir haben es halt passieren lassen,
dass wir überhaupt diese Werbekram zu tolerieren,
dass wir uns da diese Monster geschaffen haben, diese Werbenetzwerke und dann
die sozialen Netzwerke, die de facto hauptsächlich dafür da waren,
uns auf der Seite zu halten.
Dementsprechend hätte das wahrscheinlich auch alles gar nicht früher stattfinden
können und auch hier brauchen wir diesen Lernprozess.
Und der ist im Bereich Tracking, Datenschutz weiter fortgeschritten als in anderen Bereichen.
Klar ist jetzt schon viel in den Brunnen gefallen, aber das ist wahrscheinlich
immer so. Es muss auch immer erst mal richtig wehtun, bevor man auch was dagegen
unternimmt, weil das andere läuft so ein bisschen unter ferner Liefen.
Besser ist einfach gar nicht bei Facebook zu sein, dann ist mir das schon ganz
egal, oder willst du den jetzt auch 10 Euro nehmen?
Da ich jetzt Facebook überhaupt nicht benutze, nicht,
also wenn es sich, also sagen wir mal so ein Social Network was mir was bringt,
es gibt ja auch Beispiele hier so Xing und LinkedIn und so weiter,
die haben ja alle ihre Premium Angebote, die bieten dann halt nochmal mehr an,
Keine Ahnung wie das jetzt sich da mit Werbung und Tracking verhält,
da hab ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt keinen Einblick.
Für mich sind leider auch diese Business Netzwerke nicht sonderlich,
also ich benutze die nicht wirklich, hab da so einen Account und krieg die ganze
Zeit immer irgendwelche Freundes oder Netzwerk Anfragen und weiß immer nicht
was ich damit anfangen soll,
was soll mir das bringen irgendwie.
Aber Mehrwert zu bezahlen und der Mehrwert kann ja auch darin bestehen,
dass man sozusagen ein anderes Revenue-Modell wählt, weil einem das besser passt so.
Deswegen hab ich zum Beispiel mit meinem YouTube-Premium so überhaupt gar kein
Problem, weil da bekomme ich einfach genau das, was ich will.
Ich zahle da was für, kriege irgendwie unlimited Content und genau null Werbung.
Also ich bin immer wieder, wenn mir Leute sagen, ja sie hätten auf YouTube eine
Werbung gesehen, dann muss ich innerlich mich immer nochmal kurz aufrechnen,
ah ja ja, richtig stimmt ja, die anderen sehen ja Werbung.
Weil das für mich schon komplett weg ist. So ist das einfach.
Finde ich für mich nicht statt, das ist einfach nicht da.
Das ist halt natürlich auch so eine, also da entsteht halt dann,
muss man auch leider sagen, natürlich schon so eine Zwei-Klassen-Gesellschaft, ne?
Und die hat, das will ich zumindest nochmal hier abschließend anbringen.
Es gab halt immer diesen ganzen Wissen und so weiter muss frei sein Gedanken mit diesem Internet.
Und der gerät natürlich ins Wanken, aber die lässt sich natürlich auch nicht
mehr so sinnvoll aufrechterhalten,
wenn man jetzt eben sieht, naja, dass wir eben doch ganz gut beraten sind,
vielleicht ein paar bezahlte Journalistinnen und Journalisten zu haben,
die nach ordentlichen Standards arbeiten und gute Arbeiten machen und das Feld
nicht irgendwie den Schreihälsen auf Twitter und Facebook überlassen wollen.
Gleichzeitig sowas wie Paywalls sind natürlich ein Problem und verschärfen sowas
nur umso mehr, wenn auf einmal die Qualitätsmedien hinter hier musst du Geld
einwerfen verschwinden.
Und es ist auch ein Unterschied, ja, dass jetzt hier der Tim,
der kann sich leisten für YouTube zu bezahlen,
kann dafür mehr YouTube-Content sehen, sieht weniger beknackte Werbung,
das wird dann eben ein Klassenproblem oder ein Einkommensdifferenzierungsding.
Was wir ja auch, jetzt haben wir die Android-Freunde bald wieder in den Kommentaren,
dabei sehen bei Leuten, die halt sehr viel Geld für Apple-Geräte ausgeben im
mobilen Bereich und zumindest von der ganzen Reihe Google-Belastungen ausgenommen
werden und für die eine Google-Belastung,
die das Gerät hat, kriegt Apple wenigstens ein paar Milliarden.
Da freuen wir uns ja dann auch.
Wer weiß wie teuer das Telefon sonst wird.
Es ist wirklich eine interessante Diskussion, weil die so viele mögliche Bereiche
hat, in die man noch reingehen könnte.
Also die letzten Jahre haben ja vor allem gezeigt, andere Finanzierungsmodelle
sind möglich und diese Wege werden auch gegangen.
Da ist ja nicht nur das Paywall-Modell oder das Abo-Modell, sondern es gibt
ja auch die freiwillige Zahlung.
Hatten wir jetzt hier schon ausführlich. Wollte jetzt nicht auf unsere Finanzierung hinaus,
ist aber im Prinzip ja genau das gleiche, aber so Modelle wie Patreon haben
ja dann auch für unabhängige Journalisten, zum Beispiel, wo du das gerade mit
den Journalisten angesprochen hast, fiel mir das ein, eben auch Revenue-Streams eröffnet.
Wie gut das im Einzelnen für die funktioniert, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
Wir sehen nur, dass es eben etwas ist,
wo wir in zunehmendem Maße auch so Einzelkämpfer haben zumindest,
die unabhängiger von Redaktionen, Zeitschriften und Verlagen agieren können,
weil sie quasi direkt berichten.
Ich sehe das bei so aufs Ausland fokussierte Journalisten, die sich um Krisengebiete kümmern.
Die berichten teilweise einfach in ihrem Blog und glaube nicht,
dass die vollständig davon leben können. Aber das spielt zumindest eine Rolle.
Und man sieht, dass das sozusagen stattfindet.
Patreon wird so schnell nicht weggehen. Und auf der anderen Seite haben wir
natürlich auch Wikipedia.
Also auch so ein Spenden Ding. Wikipedia ist bis heute werbungsfrei.
Yeah. Super. Finde ich super.
Finde ich richtig, richtig gut, dass die da von Anfang an immer das Rückgrat
gehabt haben zu sagen, wir wollen keine Werbung auf Wikipedia haben,
weil wenn wir eine Werbung auf Wikipedia haben, dann ist das das Ende von Wikipedia
und das ist absolut richtig.
Das wäre der Tod sofort.
Da sind wir wahrscheinlich auch noch auf dem Weg in gewisser Hinsicht.
Das muss sich auch alles erstmal auskäsen.
Zukunft muss noch liefern.
Ja, ich glaube man kann natürlich, ich mache da glaube ich auch so einen leichten
Unterschied zwischen, wo ist das Produkt?
Und bei diesen sozialen Netzwerken haben wir ja zum Glück gemerkt,
dass das einfach ein teuflisches Geschäftsmodell ist und es wird jetzt auch
nicht besser dadurch, dass Facebook irgendwie um DSGVO auszutricksen eine Bezahloption einführt.
Die sind eh verloren. Also der Laden ist verloren.
Und das mit diesem Bezahlmodell ist nur etwas, um die Leute dazu zu bringen,
diese Einwilligung zu erteilen, zu einem Geschäftsmodell, was hoffentlich irgendwann
einfach mal erledigt ist.
Also das muss einfach mal weg. Oder, also...
Zumindest in diesem sozialen Bereich, bei Zugang zu Nachrichten sehe ich das
dann auch wieder ein bisschen anders.
Ein bisschen wechselhaft, glaube ich.
Na gut.
Kommen wir zu den richtigen Security Problemen.
Es gab eine interessante Meldung
die Tage, die in Deutschland gar nicht so großartig behandelt wurde.
Und zwar gibt es einen Java-Server-Betreiber unter dem Namen java.ru.
Jabba ist so ein Instant-Messaging-Protokoll, das, ja, also wenn du mich fragst,
das ist schon alles ein bisschen in die Jahre gekommen.
Der CCC betreibt auch Jabba-Server, oder Leute aus dem CCC betreiben Jabba-Server.
Das ist so ein altes Instant-Messager-Protokoll.
Du kannst auf dem Server sein, du kannst auch Cross-Server kommunizieren, ähnlich wie E-Mail.
Bei Java relativ beliebt ist sowas wie OTR, dann noch als Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung obendrauf.
Kann man noch mehr über Java sagen? Also das Protokoll XMPP,
ja, ich glaub inzwischen gibt's elegantere Protokolle, aber es hält sich in
gewissen Kreisen noch so ein bisschen, oder? Das ist zumindest so ein Standard.
Es ist ein föderierter Instant Messaging Standard und das seit bestimmt,
keine Ahnung, 20 Jahren oder so?
Ja, gibt es schon lange jetzt. Weiß auch gar nicht, seit wann gibt es Jabber?
Also ich glaube schon, dass ich es relativ lange benutze.
Seit 2004 ist es ein Standard.
Hätte jetzt auch so 20 Jahre geschätzt.
So da gibt es unterschiedliche Anbieter und du kannst dir deinen Java Server
Betreiber natürlich frei wählen.
Registrierst dann deinen Account und dann jabberst du eben darüber.
Sieht dann am Ende aus wie, also typischerweise benutzt man einen.
Ein Client natürlich dafür, ja. Und der sieht dann gerne mal so aus wie,
muss man sich so vorstellen wie ICQ, AIM, AOL Instant Messenger.
Was waren denn noch so welche?
Gab es da noch einen? Die beiden waren das so, ne?
Am Anfang ja, also ICQ war das erste,
aus Israel glaube ich und AIM aus Amerika von AOL hat dann sehr schnell die
Popularität sogar noch überschritten von ICQ.
Und ich glaube ICQ ist auch, ist das irgendwann da eingeflossen?
Ich weiß nicht mehr so ganz genau.
Genau, aber du hattest einfach, und ich glaube das ist lustig,
weil die Leute, ich kenne auch immer noch meine ICQ Nummer.
Ja die werde ich jetzt hier nicht sagen, aber ich kenne sie noch.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich die alle hatte, doch ich glaube auch.
Ja doch klar, das war ja Irrsinn, dass du da so ein Fensterchen rechts am Bildschirmrand
hast und dann immer so, oh oh, was wird denn deine Kumpel schreiben,
das war schon irgendwie spitze.
Also es war einfach schon eine bessere Integration,
als vorher irgendwie mit Bitch-Ex im IRC rumhängen, was allenfalls mal gepiept
hat, wenn du dir vorher irgendwie ein Skript für die Funktion geschrieben hast
oder so, nee, nee, das war schon...
Das war schon ganz gut mit dem ICQ.
Und Java, was benutzt man da? Pidgin ist, glaube ich, auf Linux der beliebte
Client, auf Mac OS, Ardium, Windows weiß ich nicht, gibt's sicherlich auch.
So, jetzt werden diese Java-Server gerne mal benutzt. Ich würde sagen,
ist schon in Hacker-Kreisen eher beliebt.
Und es hat so ein bisschen, ich glaub, den Vorteil dadurch, dass das einfach
nicht so verbreitet ist, aber eigentlich jeder Techie schon irgendwie einen
Java-Account hat, hat sich das eigentlich ganz gut gehalten,
um da so ein bisschen unter sich zu bleiben.
Und jetzt gibt es also einen Java-Serverbetreiber unter der Domain java.ru und
xmpp.ru und der hat Server offensichtlich gehostet,
was das ist der einzige Teil, den ich an der Story so ein bisschen schwer nachvollziehbar fand.
Derzeit ist Server offenbar bei Hetzner und bei Linode stehen.
Hetzner ist ein relativ großer Server-Hoster aus und größtenteils auch in Deutschland.
Die sind dafür bekannt, relativ günstig zu sein. Zum Beispiel auch dadurch,
dass sie jetzt nicht unbedingt Enterprise-Server-Hardware verwenden,
sondern auch einfach mal normale Consumer-Festplatten da reinschnacken und dir
dadurch halt einen günstigen Server anbieten.
Und Linode ist ein US-Anbieter, glaube ich, aber die haben auch offenbar weltweit
und auch in Deutschland was stehen.
Und dieser Java.ru betreibt also mehrere XMPP-Server, hat da irgendwie ein Load
Balancer davor und irgendwie kriegt der das halt hin.
Und jetzt stellte der auf einmal fest, bei der Verbindung zu Java.ru,
dass das Zertifikat abgelaufen war. Auf einem seiner Server.
Also das TLS-Zertifikat.
Wer stellte das fest?
Der Administrator des Servers. Sicherlich auch viele andere,
die werden ja auch die Zertifikatswarnung bekommen haben, aber die Geschichte
beginnt mit dem Administrator des Servers.
Und dann denkt er sich, hä komisch warum ist denn mein letztes Encrypt-Zertifikat abgelaufen?
Also das sind die Verschlüsselungszertifikate, die für das TLS zuständig sind,
dafür dass da oben das Schloss im Browser ist. Das habt ihr sicherlich auch
schon öfter mal beim Besuch einer Webseite gesehen, dass da manchmal steht, ist abgelaufen.
Bei Let's Encrypt laufen die, glaube ich, gerade standardmäßig so nach drei Monaten ab.
So und dann denkst du natürlich als Administrator, denkst du,
oh komisch, mein Zertifikat ist abgelaufen, normalerweise hast du dein Let's
Encrypt Service so konfiguriert, dass der die automatisch sich erneuert.
Da hast du eigentlich so einen Cron-Job laufen, der, was weiß ich,
machst halt einmal im Monat oder wenn du sicher gehen willst,
einmal die Woche, dass der guckt, ob das Zertifikat noch gültig ist und wenn
das so in dem Rahmen ist, wo man mal langsam das verlängern sollte oder ein
neues ausstellen lassen sollte, holt der sich halt ein neues.
So, und wenn du jetzt an deinem eigenen Server eine Zertifikatswarnung kriegst,
dann gehst du eigentlich hin und guckst, naja, was hab ich denn da falsch gemacht,
worum ist denn mein Zertifikat abgelaufen.
Muss auf jeden Fall fixen, weil Leute können gerade nicht darauf zugreifen. So,
und in der Untersuchung stellt dieser gute Mann fest, das Zertifikat,
was ich da gerade gezeigt kriege und was abgelaufen ist, ist eines,
was ich nie ausgestellt habe.
Also er findet dieses Zertifikat nicht auf seinem Server.
Das ist sehr überraschend und das sollte nicht passieren.
Und beobachtet dieses Phänomen eben bei zwei Servern, die sich in Deutschland befinden.
Und sieht dann eben über Zertifikats-Transparenzlisten und so weiter,
dass es dieses Zertifikat eben, dass es mehrere Zertifikate glaube ich sogar gab,
die für seine Server ausgestellt wurden, die er nicht ausgestellt hatte.
Und da gibt es ja auch so einen Screenshot in dieser Darstellung,
wo er dann sagt, okay, jetzt mache ich mal den Wireshark an,
also ich schneide den Netzwerktraffic mit auf meinem Server und den Netzwerktraffic auf meinem Client.
Und dann sieht man, dass der Client ein anderes Zertifikat sieht,
die Verbindung aber trotzdem beim Server ankommt, nur unter einem anderen Port.
Und die verbinden sich völlig problemlos, reden dann auch schön XMPP miteinander,
weil alle denken, ist ja super, aber das, was der Client sieht,
ist nicht das Zertifikat, was der Server sieht.
Und das nennt man eine Machine-in-the-Middle-Attacke.
Ja, das heißt, da ist ein Rechner zwischen, der hat ein Zertifikat,
damit auch den Schlüssel dafür, und alle Verbindungen, die dort eingehen,
leitet der dann weiter an den anderen und bricht dazwischen einmal die Verschlüsselung.
Und offenbar war diesem MITM-Rechner, der vor seinem hängt, das Zertifikat jetzt
offenbar abgelaufen. Jetzt denkst
du dir, ja, scheiße, Wie kommt der denn überhaupt an dieses Zertifikat?
Und eigentlich gibt es nur zwei Wege, wie du dir ein Zertifikat fälschlich ausstellen kannst.
Der eine wäre, du musst den DNS-Eintrag manipulieren,
sodass Let's Encrypt, wenn es prüft bei der Zertifikatsausstellung,
ob du auch die Kontrolle über diese Domain hast, dass du die halt zu dir lenkst.
Oder du hast den, der DNS-Eintrag stimmt,
den veränderst du auch nicht, aber du kannst das Routing zu dieser IP-Adresse
verändern, weil du zum Beispiel derjenige bist, der diese IP-Adresse announce
und bis zu sich ins Rechenzentrum routet.
Und was hier jetzt offenbar passiert ist und ich bin jetzt so ein bisschen vor,
also dieser technische Bericht ist, wenn er nicht wahr ist,
sei jetzt ganz vorsichtig, ist der enorm gut gefälscht,
weil der perfekt danach aussieht, also genau so würde man es machen und der
ist in meiner Lesart absolut schlüssig,
bis auf die Tatsache, dass der seine Server ausgerechnet bei Hetzner und Linode
in Deutschland stehen hat, wenn es Jabber.ru ist.
Also, was stellt er fest? Auf seinem Server, der, der diese TLS-Terminierung macht,
der hat irgendwann einmal für ein paar Sekunden, für ungefähr 30 Sekunden, 19 Sekunden, am 18.
Juli die Internetverbindung verloren. Also seine Netzwerk, seine Netzwerk-Anbindung
ist runtergegangen und ist wieder hochgegangen und danach hat sich so ein paar
Dinge an seinem Netzwerk verändert,
zum Beispiel kann er andere nicht mehr pingen, die er vorher pingen konnte.
Was also potenziell passiert ist, da wurde einfach dieser In The Middle Server
zwischengeschaltet und der hat sich dann,
weil er quasi jetzt unter dieser IP-Adresse ist, ein Zertifikat geholt,
sich das ausstellen lassen und ab dann kann der ja für dich antworten und der
ist jetzt einfach davor geschaltet.
Und jetzt ist er der Sache auf den Grund gegangen und hat halt Tracing und so weiter,
Das zeigt dann auch den Unterschied zwischen unterschiedlichen Linode-Servern
in Deutschland und woanders, wie die sich verhalten, wie die Traceroutes aussehen
und so. Das ist schon alles ganz ordentlich.
Lange Rede kurzer Sinn, sieht danach aus,
als hätten sowohl Linode als auch Hetzner hier einen MITM-Angriff auf ihren
eigenen Kunden gemacht,
das werden die sicherlich nicht von alleine machen und eine Geschichte,
die dazu sehr gut passt, wäre, dass es eine Anordnung gab von deutschen Behörden das zu tun, ne?
Deutsche Behörden auf Linode.
Linode Server in Deutschland.
Achso, Linode Server in Deutschland. Das ist also ausschließlich auf deutschen Servern passiert.
Genau, also der hat einen Hetzner Server in Deutschland und einen Linode Server
in Deutschland und er hat andere Linode Server die nicht in Deutschland stehen, da ist das nicht so.
Das ist ja ein bisschen...
Ja, also ich würde jetzt mal so, so wie das jetzt geschildert ist,
er sagt also spätestens seit dem 21. Juli bis zum 19.
Oktober, potenziell aber seit
dem 18. April. Und das betrifft alle XMPP-TLS-Verbindungen auf Port 52.22.
Er hatte irgendwie noch Port 52.23, was nicht.
Und der Angreifer hat dann eben versäumt, sich ein neues TLS-Zertifikat für sein Proxy zu holen.
Und ja, dadurch ist es aufgefallen. Und dann kurz danach,
nachdem sie begonnen haben, das zu untersuchen, wo sie auch Tickets an Hetzner
und Linnot geschrieben haben und sagten so, hier, da stimmt was nicht mit unserem Server.
Die Tickets sind aber auch verschwunden und sie sagen also, zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
ist das passive Mitschneiden, also ein zusätzlicher Routing-Loop ist immer noch da,
bei zumindest einem Server, bei Linode, aber die greifen nicht mehr aktiv ein
in die Verschlüsselung.
Sagt aber auch, klar, das heißt, beide Server wurden nicht gehackt,
weil wenn die gehackt worden wären, dann hätte man sich einfach davon die Keys
geholt zu den Zertifikaten und hätte das nicht mehr gebraucht.
Und die Netzwerke wurden bei Hetzner und Linnod offenbar spezifisch dafür umkonfiguriert,
sodass ihm das nicht so einfach aufgefallen ist.
Und jetzt müsste man sich natürlich nochmal anschauen, wie das XMPP-Protokoll
zum Beispiel die Authentifizierung macht.
Also ich glaube nämlich, iJabba,
die den der benutzt, das ist schon etwas älteres Software und das könnte sein,
dass die gar nicht so großartig alles umgesetzt hat,
was man so heute macht, das habe ich mir aber nicht angeschaut,
aber ja sieht auf jeden Fall,
also es ist eine extrem glaubhafte Geschichte, so würdest du halt einen behördlich
angeordneten MITM-Angriff auf einen Jabba-Server machen.
Für Leute, die nicht zusätzlich zu ihrem Jabber dann noch OTR oder so machen,
würde das dann eben bedeuten, dass da alles, was da stattgefunden hat,
erstmal mitgeschnitten werden konnte.
Du kannst aber natürlich auch dann in dem.
Protokoll-Stream durchaus potenziell feststellen und sagen, okay,
dann verfolgst du halt das Protokoll nach und sagst,
okay, hier, ich entnehme dem, dass das jetzt gerade eine Kommunikation mit meiner
Zielperson oder für meine Zielperson ist und dass du dann da zielgerichtet vorgehst. Mh, ja.
Aber ich fand's auf jeden Fall spannend.
Ja, Management Summary für alle, die bei all den ganzen Abkürzungen komplett ausgestiegen sind.
Es macht so den Eindruck, als ob es bei Hetzner und bei Linode in Deutschland
irgendwie vermutlich vom Unterwissen des Hosters Möglichkeiten gibt,
mal eben zumindest für bestimmte Protokolle,
wie in diesem Fall mit diesem Java Server, Mal eben kurz die Verbindungen zu hijacken,
also die Pakete nicht an den eigentlichen Rechner zu routen,
der dafür zuständig ist,
sondern etwas in der Mitte, der dann mal eben selber die Zertifikatsverhandlungen
führt, die man eigentlich selber führen möchte und sich dann sozusagen dazwischen geschoben hat.
Und nachdem das dann aufgefallen ist und nachdem da auch ein paar Support-Tickets
gestartet wurden, dann gab es auf einmal diese auffällige Tätigkeit nicht mehr.
Obwohl hier glaube ich noch von so einem kleinen Umweg bei den Hops noch berichtet
wird, also ein bisschen mitgeschnitten wird dann trotzdem noch.
Aber irgendjemand hat sich dann wohl ein bisschen ertappt gefühlt.
Also es könnte echt sein, dass sie dafür das Tool MITM-Proxy benutzt haben und
den kannst du halt an und aus machen, ne?
Da kannst du halt einfach sagen, ja okay, route mal von hier nach da und lass
mal kurz den aktiven Angriff sein, dann fließt das einfach wieder alles durch.
Ich frage mich halt, es liegt nahe,
dass das ein Angriff von staatlicher Stelle war, ich habe ein paar Vorstellungen,
worum der sich vielleicht gedreht hat.
Also es gibt Ransomware-Gangs, die vielleicht sich auf sowas,
auf solchen Servern rumtreiben.
Es gibt, könnte was damit zu tun haben.
Also das ist schon, ja, also das ist erstmal eine plausible Schilderung, so was natürlich.
Die Sache so ein bisschen ist, den ganzen Server direkt hops zu nehmen ist halt
ein relativ breiter Zugriff.
Jetzt kann man natürlich wieder sagen, damit hätten sie jetzt potenziell erstmal
alle Connections dahin mitschneiden können und auch jede Kommunikation.
Und wenn die Kommunikation, wenn sie Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt war,
dann zumindest immer noch die Metadaten, wer wann mit wem kommuniziert hat und
wie viel und wie lange die Pausen und so waren.
Das ist schon ein relativ üppiger Zugriff.
Bin mal gespannt, ob wir da noch irgendwie was hören von den Ermittlungsergebnissen oder ob,
ob der, also das Thema scheint nicht so hochgekocht zu sein,
sodass sich jetzt auch nicht so wirklich jemand da, also im Moment ist da glaube
ich noch niemand unter, unter Rechtfertigungsdruck.
Ja mal gucken ob das noch kommt.
So damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung angekommen.
Genau sind wir am Ende der Sendung.
Ist dann doch noch ein bisschen länger geworden.
Wenn du unbedingt Facebook kostenlos benutzen willst ohne dich tracken zu lassen.
Jetzt steigen wir ein.
Du wolltest mit Log2Netzpolitik immer auf Facebook und ich immer nicht.
Wir sind da immer noch, wir sind da, wir haben eine Facebookseite,
ich habe irgendeinen automatischen Webdienst, der pastet da jedes Ding hin.
Ach das löschen wir mal, das ist doch Quatsch.
Ne da kommentieren auch Leute, lass.
Das ist nicht dein Ernst.
Doch ich hab da letztens reingeguckt.
Echt?
Hier Facebook.
Wir kommentieren Leute auf Facebook. Das ist das Problem, wenn du auf so einem
Service präsent bist, aber du bist da eigentlich gar nicht präsent. Was soll denn das?
Naja okay gut.
Es ist ein Werbe-Netzwerk und wir werben da kostenlos. Was willst du mehr?
Guck hier. Hier willst du nicht sehen. Mit deinen Bildern und allem. Die werden da direkt.
Aber okay, das heißt wir werben da, dann könnten wir uns doch auch dafür bezahlen
lassen, dass wir nicht werben.
Das wäre doch super.
Zehn Euro.
Dann hören wir auf auf Facebook zu posten.
Da hättest du immer drauf hinweisen können. Bei uns könnt ihr auch zehn Euro
zahlen, da hindert euch niemand dran.
Und was wir machen ist, bei uns ist es sogar so, wir machen einfach genauso weiter.
Das ist doch viel cooler, also Facebook sagt auch, alles genauso wie vorher,
aber keine Werbung. Bei uns war nie Werbung, also ist alles genau wie vorher,
10 Euro, zack, finde ich einen fairen Deal.
Und außerdem könnt ihr ja für uns Werbung machen, das dürft ihr ja nicht vergessen.
Das kostet allerdings Geld, für uns Werbung zu machen.
Da müsst ihr in unseren Shop gehen, könnt ein T-Shirt kaufen,
dann könnt ihr Werbeträger werden für uns.
Also ich verstehe warum das andere sich durchgesetzt hat, aber ich finde unseren Ansatz charmanter.
Ja ich auch. Oh Gott ich muss da glaube ich mal ein paar Sachen löschen auf
Facebook, das geht alles gar nicht.
Oh gibt's da was von dir?
Naja, irgendwelchen Experimenten gibts irgendwie in dem Meta eben,
Profil oder wie das heißt, keine Ahnung, da ist natürlich nichts drauf,
aber auf Logbuchnetz wirklich ist auch nichts drauf.
Ach da kommen hin Leute, du kannst da irgendwo hingehen.
Also wenn ich da drauf gehe, dann kommt da gar nichts. Manage Page,
hier kommt auch, was ist das hier?
Ne bei mir kommt da, hier prophetisches perfekt, Enkel Trick beim Hackersilber, die Bilder.
Jetzt hab ich das auch, das ist so furchtbar auf diesem Facebook.
Grauner. Grauner. Aber das liest doch kein Mensch.
Die sind da immer Daumen drunter, hier drei mal gefällt mir.
Was? Tatsache.
Sechs mal gefällt mir. Drei. Vier. Aha.
Für die drei Daumennamen machen wir hier irgendwie so eine Präsenz auf die Böse.
Machen wir ja nicht, wir machen doch gar nichts, das macht alles irgendein Skript.
Das ist doch eine Ausrede, wir sind doch hier, wir sind doch hier da,
wir unterstützen doch dieses ausbeuterische System durch unsere Präsenz.
Wieso kriegt man das eigentlich bei Facebook nicht um die Ohren,
warum muss man sich das immer nur bei Twitter vorwerfen lassen?
Weiß ich nicht.
Das ist alles ungerecht.
Aber ich tendiere dazu Sachen einfach zu löschen, wenn ich die nicht wirklich brauche und benutze.
Deswegen willst du ja auch nur ein Iphone mit 256 Gig.
Ja das reicht mir auch.
Echt so wenig?
Ja der Rest ist in der Cloud.
Dann brauchen wir das ja nicht mehr.
Das ist, ne klar, das kann ich verstehen. Dann brauchen wir ja keinen eigenen
Speicherplatz mehr, wenn das.
Gut, zum Abschluss noch ein bisschen Propaganda aus China und wir hören uns
dann nächste Woche wieder, nehme ich mal an.
Vielleicht bis dahin mehr passiert, dann müssen wir nicht so die Auseinandersetzung
mit Belanglosigkeiten hier so in die Länge ziehen.
Belanglosigkeit. Super Feedback. Achso, ja Feedback schon.
Feedback schon, aber die anderen Themen. Man muss auch diese Diskussion führen,
ich glaub das ist auch für uns gut, also für mich zumindest,
dass man das einfach mal so ein bisschen quetscht und einfach mal ein paar Aspekte sieht.
Gerade bei diesem KI Thema sind wir noch lange nicht mit durch.
Ne, meinst du das setzt sich durch? Meinst du da werden wir nochmal drüber sprechen müssen?
Ich hab so den Anflug einer Vermutung auf jeden Fall. Jetzt machen wir aber erstmal tschüss hier.
Leute bis später. Macht's gut.
Bis denn. Ciao ciao.